Mass Effect 3 is a roller coaster of
emotions for me it's got an incredible
start but a terrible ending it also has
some wonderful decisions that can
reshape the whole story but it also has
choices that are pointless either
because the difference is barely
noticeable or just completely Rewritten
to fit the story it is a very stressful
game to play because one moment the
story is on a roll and really starts to
pick up speed but then falls back down
almost immediately it is a game that has
disappointed me greatly and today I want
to talk about why so without further Ado
let's get started
so Mass Effect 3 starts six months after
Mass Effect 2. Shepard and enormity have
been grounded here on Earth because of
one of two things either because Shepard
blew up the Mastery Lake killing 300 000
batarians if you played the arrival DLC
or because they worked with Cerberus if
you didn't do the DLC similar to Mass
Effect 2 our crewmates are nowhere to be
seen we'll meet them all eventually
later but it seems like Shepard told the
crew to go their separate ways and turn
themselves in so that no one else had to
deal with the interrogations that would
come after already though we're already
introduced to one of our choices the
human Ambassador odino replaces Anderson
as counselor in Mass Effect 3 regardless
of your decision even if you chose
Anderson in Mass Effect 1 your decision
is reverted to the one BioWare wanted
you to choose so as a whole the
counselor decision from Mass Effect 1 is
pointless not only can your decision
possibly get changed without your input
but Anderson and udina barely made an
appearance in Mass Effect 2 save 4-1
side mission and even then the change at
most is a liner 2 of dialogue after
meeting with Anderson we then meet with
the vermeyer Survivor and James Vega Jay
James as well as Ashley arcadin
depending on who lived will be a part of
our new crew I want to hold off on the
companion analysis until we get everyone
on board so we'll Circle back to them
later also anytime I say Ashley I also
mean Caden it would just get tedious if
I kept repeating both of their names all
the time as you may have noticed though
it's only been a couple of minutes into
the video and we already have two
comparisons across the playthroughs
unlike the previous videos we'll be
talking about the Renegade playthrough a
lot in this video as this game has the
most changes between our Paragon and
Renegade characters one Shepard talks
with Ashley for a bit he will then meet
with the alliance Council and discuss
his crimes he also briefly mentions the
Reapers and how they plan to attack soon
soon must apparently mean now as right
after this the Reapers attack Earth
one thing I like about the Reapers in
Mass Effect 3 is how they always go for
the throat throughout the game we'll
learn about Reaper attacks on palaven
tachanka and decia which are the
homeworlds of the turians Krogan and
asari respectively the reapers are all
about going for big targets and taking
them out as soon as possible this shows
off their overwhelming power because if
the home planet can't defeat them how is
a colony at the edge of the Milky Way
going to defeat them as well Shepard
though is going to be one of the Unlucky
few that's going to be seen that
Destruction for themselves within
minutes the Reapers have shown the tide
of battle and have destroyed everything
in sight Earth isn't completely gone yet
but seeing how much Destruction has
already been caused in just a few
minutes it's only a matter of time while
Anderson Shepard and Ashley Escape
Shepherd will come across this little
kid hiding in the vents this kid will
eventually be seen hopping into a
shuttle before it blows up this death
really affects Shepard a lot throughout
the game Shepard will have these dreams
where he chases this kid through the
forest this kid is meant to be a
representation of Shepard's struggle and
Trauma that's because the kid is just
that a kid someone who doesn't deserve
this Sim was never a part of the war to
begin with
a common sentiment amongst the Army is
that their fighting set those back home
can be free but in this case that idea
has failed Shepard and the crew fight to
make sure the Galaxy and its innocent
inhabitants can live Carefree lives but
the reapers are just too powerful now
every man woman and child has been swept
up into this war whether they like it or
not it's quite a scary thought which is
why I really like this game's intro so
much there's no cool or hyped up
introduction where everyone's gearing up
and getting ready it's a surprise attack
against an ill-equipped species that has
no idea what they're even fighting
furthermore the intro still shows how
powerful the reapers are and honestly I
think this holds up throughout the whole
game the only Reaper that has died so
far was Sovereign back in Mass Effect 1
and it took a lot of Firepower to bring
it down Mass Effect 3 recognized this
and made sure that any time a Reaper
dies in this game it's either because of
overwhelming damage or unconventional
means this was inevitably something the
team was going to have to tackle and
instead of making the Reapers weak for
the purposes of gameplay they continue
to uphold their strength which I really
appreciated because of that though we
aren't going to be shooting many Reapers
in this game which is why we fight a lot
of troops like the husks this is also
another problem the team would have to
tackle because having all the enemies be
all husks or all Geth is boring so they
need to add variety but BioWare not only
succeeded in creating a variety of
enemies but also made it more accurate
using a plot device I was hoping would
return we know from Mass Effect 1 and 2
that the Reapers can repurpose species
to their liking husks are just
repurposed humans and the collectors
were originally protheans BioWare
continued this idea but extended it to
the other species wound up meeting new
enemies like the Marauders brutes
cannibals and banshees all of them are
repurposed versions of another alien
species cannibals used to be batarians
Marauders used to be turians brutes have
the discipline and determination of
eturian but the strength of a Krogan and
the Banshees used to be ardadiakshi this
not only makes the combat more diverse
and interesting but also the story as
well now the lore nerded me would have
loved to see more variations from the
other races like the solarians and
quarians but I'm content with what we
got but as I said the story takes a more
Sinister turn thanks to this idea
because allies can now become enemies so
it's not just about defeating the reaper
forces but also making sure no one dies
in the process it's unclear whether or
not the person needs to be dead or alive
for them to be turned into these things
but it still paints a very Bleak picture
every loss is the Reaper's gain now and
they already have the odds stacked in
their favor this is just salt in the
wound at this point getting back on
track one Shepherd and Anderson get to a
more secure location the Normandy comes
by to pick them up but Anderson decides
to stay behind enter's implants do stay
here on Earth and fight the good fight
while Shepard goes and gets help from
the council given their insistence on
not even recognizing the reaper threat
we can assume that it's going to be an
uphill battle before we do that though
Admiral Hackett gets on the comms and
instructs Shepherd to go to an alliance
base on Mars before the system is
destroyed one thing I must give credit
to Mass Effect 3-4 is how much attention
was given to Hackett in the first two
games he was just sort of a higher up
that occasionally gave orders he still
does that to an extent but his role is
much larger in this game the same also
goes for Anderson as well which is
something I was very happy to see as
they are very likable characters Hackett
wants upper to go to the space on Mars
because the people here have been
searching prothean archives for ways to
fight the Reapers and who of all people
do you think is leading This research
team the one and only Dr Liara to Sony
Liara not only has lots of knowledge on
the prothean people but she also has the
resources of the Shadow broker so she's
able to help out in many different ways
according to Liar Within These archives
was a blueprint for a device called The
Crucible this was apparently a prothean
weapon that was supposed to defeat the
Reapers clearly it failed but that's
because they were missing a crucial
piece called The Catalyst what the
Catalyst actually is is unknown for now
which is fine because we still have to
build The Crucible but before that
happens we run into a familiar face who
is less than pleased with our rival
Shepherd
The elusive Man shows up by a hologram
and basically taunts Shepard telling
them that he will fail and that he has a
plan of his own that'll be more
successful basically The elusive man
wants to control the Reapers he believes
that dominating the Reapers is how they
win because not only will they stop the
threat but they'll have the most
advanced civilization under their
control it's a risky goal but risky is
his middle name he spent billions of
credits surviving one man and then sent
his team on a suicide mission with the
hopes of stopping the collectors if this
was anyone else in the Mass Effect
Universe I would immediately lose
interest in this idea but the elusive
man has shown that he has the assets and
the power to get [ __ ] done so while the
idea of controlling the Reapers does
seem ludicrous with him at the helm it
might not be cerber is showing up at the
Mars base also creates some tension
between Shepard and the vermeier
Survivor the last time we met both
Ashley and Kaden were very upset at
Shepard's willingness to work with
Cerberus even if it was just a means to
an end six months later and it's still
the same similar to our meeting with
them on Horizon not only do the two not
trust Shepard they also have the same
dialogue Mass Effect has always
committed to this idea that people will
not believe Shepard even with all the
evidence laid out in front of them this
was the same problem Shepard had with
the council back in the first game and
even then it was drawn out and tedious
but Mass Effect is doing it again by
continuing to bring up how Shepard
worked with Cerberus and is therefore a
bad guy it's starting to become
overplayed even in the same Mission
Ashley and Shepard have a talk about his
past with Cerberus to which Shepard juts
her down saying that they were only
working together because of their common
goal then later they find out that some
of the Cerberus soldiers have been
modified and they seem to look like
Reaper husks without skipping a beat the
first thing they will say is what if
you're being controlled you don't know
what they put in you or if they're even
controlling you this is already third on
its face and we haven't even gotten to
the Citadel attack yet as an isolated
incident I feel like this wouldn't be
that bad but since everyone seems to
ignore Shepard throughout the whole
trilogy this interaction with them
really sticks out once the group has
their chat with the elusive man they end
up finding a Dr Ava core who was seen
sabotaging the facility at one point on
the security cams Dr Ava realizes that
she's been made and makes a break for it
she almost gets away until James Rams
his shuttle into theirs crashing them
both this should have killed the crew
but it seems like Dr Ava was synthetic
and not actually human she then takes
this opportunity to critically injure
Ashley before being put down by Shepard
both Ashley and Dr Ava are then taken to
the Normandy and the crew determines
that taking Ashley to the hospital on
the Citadel is the only way to save her
e also decides to figure out if she can
inhabit Dr Ava's body and it
surprisingly Works similar to Legion
Edie now has a mobile platform she can
walk around in and now that she is
mobile she can now join us on some of
our missions once we make it to the
Citadel we're then told to meet with the
council but we can take a look around a
bit as we can talk to some old friends
The Citadel in Mass Effect 3 seems a bit
lackluster in some aspects a lot of the
areas are small and linear whereas Mass
Effect 1 had a lot more space to it
that's not to say all of them are bad
though as the presidium commons has a
lot more twists and turns in its design
one thing that has stayed consistent
across each game is the level's detail
the docking area is filled with refugees
of all Races and there are so many
different things happening at once
people are checking in some are getting
medical attention and others are just
sulking around some of the crew will
also appear on the various levels which
makes things more realistic and it
allows for more conversations between
you and the crew while exploring the
floors of the Citadel you'll likely run
across Dr shockwas and Ashley Dr chakwas
is here talking with a Dr Michelle who I
had no idea was from Mass Effect 1. way
back in the beginning when we first met
Garrison Rex we were tasked with hunting
down a guy named fist while some of his
goons attacked Dr Michelle but we were
able to save her when speaking with Dr
chakwas though we can offer her a spot
on the Norma Deegan and she happily
accepts as for Ashley she's still
unconscious for now but you can can say
a few words to her if you want once our
Affairs are in order we can meet with
the council and discuss the reaper
threat this is also the first time we've
met the council in person since Mass
Effect 1 and if you remember from the
end of that game we also had the choice
of saving them or letting them die and
judging by their demeanor it seems like
the old council is doing all right but
Keen viewers may have recognized that I
am lying to you this is not the old
Council but rather the new one the two
biggest changes are that the solarian
counselor is female and the turian has a
different colored face paint furthermore
both councils reinstate our Specter
status in Mass Effect 2 it was possible
to knock at your Specter status back
which to be fair didn't really mean much
in that game since we were operating out
of console space for the most part but
regardless of our choice it just gets
reinstated anyway if anything this
should have been the game to commit to
this change as just down the hall is the
Specter only room in here are Specter
exclusive weapons and armor but also a
terminal that only specters can use this
allows you to give authority to specific
requests for example people two
Engineers were detained by the alliance
but can be released these two also
happen to be Donnelly and Daniels from
Mass Effect 2. most of these choices
aren't too important so it's not like
you'd be missing a critical part of the
story by not having your Specter status
plus this could have led to alternate
paths and other side missions such as
this one where a Solari inspector needs
you to authorize something but because
you aren't A specter the side mission
could change a bit it doesn't have to be
a completely different outcome but just
small enough to show that the mission
has changed I also want to bring up
something before we continue because
it's quite critical to understanding
Mass Effect 3. just like in the previous
games you can import your old characters
that your choices retain continuity the
only difference though is that in Mass
Effect 3 the game tells you what those
decisions were this not only shows the
player what they chose but also what
choices matter we've made a lot of
decisions throughout the course of this
series but some are more important than
others especially in Mass Effect 3. for
example saving the colonists on Pharaoh
seemed quite important at the time but
according to Mass Effect 3 it's not as
important as it's not on the list and we
can even see this in game as the most
that Quest did was give us additional
War assets something I'll talk about
later it's still important but not as
important as something like the council
or the rachni queen as another example
we can see that Maitland's data is
mentioned that data was a part of
morden's loyalty Quest but what makes
him so special we stopped in ardad
yakshi and samara's Mission destroyed a
biota camp in Jax and stole back a gray
box that could have sparked a war in
kasumi's Mission so why is Morton so
important that's because maelin's data
was about the Gen of age which is a
critical part of Mass Effect 3's plot as
we'll see in just a few moments I wanted
to go over this because the game is
basically telling us that out of all the
decisions we've made across the game
these are the ones that will have the
most impact however this only applies to
some of them such as the bottom bullet
points that talk about romance those
were more for the player to remember who
their lover is as Romancing has never
had a direct impact on the story so out
of this list I would say the most
important ones that aren't just there to
remind the player but actually have
potential to alter the game's story are
the rachnine queen the council May Lin's
data rewriting the Geth and The
Collector base
the others are just nice to know details
Rex being alive or dead changes the
mission on tachanka but doesn't alter it
too much and choosing one vermeyer
Survivor over the other doesn't change
much either at least when it comes to
the main quest already though we are
over one because the council's decision
is just as useless as the human
Ambassador not only do the councils
practically look the same but they also
act the same as well they have the same
dialogue and the same reactions to the
missions when we report back to them the
only actual difference is that they
become a part of a point system
wondering a future Citadel Mission and
the other being the war assets War
assets are the main motivator for doing
content in this game and are integral to
getting a good ending as well
I don't really like the war asset system
but it's not because of one isolated
reason it would be too hard to talk
about that all at once so we'll have to
Circle back to the system periodically
throughout the video if you save the
console then you get the destiny
Ascension as a war asset if not then
you'll get a few more aligned ships
instead since they would have been
sacrificed to save the asari ship
technically saving the council is the
better choice since the destiny
Ascension provides more war assets than
the alliance Fleet but that is one of
the only changes this decision has this
makes the council's decision no more
important than the colonists on Pharaoh
since they also give us War assets but
shouldn't that mean that the colonists
should appear on the list since they
have the same outcome and therein lies
the problem Mass Effect 3 claims that
saving the council was important but
both of our Shepherds arrived at the
same outcome ultimately making this
decision a waste of time
as you would expect talking with the
council doesn't go well they finally
recognize the reaper threat though
they're just three years too late but
refused to help earth and its citizens
thankfully the eturian councilor has a
plan but we have to strike a deal
because nothing involving the council is
ever simple a turian called Primark
fedorian called the war Summit but it
was unsuccessful War Summits are used to
determine where races send their fleets
and resources we need the Primark to
start the summit but as we'll soon see
not only is the Primark dead but the new
one has his own deal involving the
Krogan but the Krogan won't budge until
the genif age is cured so we have to
cure the genophage to appease the Krogan
so they can send reinforcements to
palavan and only then will the Primark
send ships to Earth said Humanity can
fight the Reapers there what a headache
thankfully getting to the Primark isn't
too difficult plus an old friend is here
fighting alongside them Garris is here
and is helping the tyrigan military as
they deem him to be a Reaper expert this
mission is also a great example of how
the game manages to patch up holes of
the story that the companions used to
occupy Garris died in our other
playthrough but because Garrus is
present in this Mission the team runs
into a problem at least for this Mission
the team opted to just remove him but in
some cases characters are replaced like
how Reeve took Rex's position in Mass
Effect 2. what makes this Mission so
special though is that it's done in such
a way that doesn't seem obvious I had
completely forgotten where Garrus was
introduced in this Mission when I went
back and played it and it was only when
I made it to the final objective that I
realized I'd already passed it the game
had managed to work around a character's
death in a way that didn't compromise
the overall story
once we get through the war-torn moon
and get the new Primark to safety we can
call the war Summit as we talked about
earlier though getting The turian Fleets
to Earth is going to involve some
complicated deals Rex is here
representing the Krogan Army and of
course he wants the genophage cured both
Primark victus and the solarian dalatras
are against this but it's the only way
as without the Krogan support palaven is
gone and if the turians are defeated
Earth can't get help so Rex's forced our
hand of it the Gen of age is one of the
most well-known pieces of History within
the Mass Effect universe and I was kind
of surprised that we were actually going
to cure it but I guess if I'm being
honest it was only a matter of time
until this was settled drastic times
call for drastic measures which is why
the mission Shepherd will have to embark
on are necessary for Galactic survival
this also showcases how broken the
relationships of these races are because
they're still reopening Old Wounds to be
fair a widespread disease that causes an
entire race to be infertile is dangerous
enough for someone to hold a grudge but
the Krogan aren't the only ones with
these grudges none of the races in the
Galaxy are actually working together and
even if they offer to help they want
something out of it Ashley even
foreshadowed this back in Mass Effect 1
where she talked about how the other
races will back each other and not worry
about others when the going gets tough
while it's getting pretty tough and
everyone is more focused on fighting
their own individual fights rather than
coming together which is the goal of
Mass Effect 3. get the races to come
together under one banner and defeat the
Reapers together but doing that is not
going to be easy to start we have to
cure the genif age and to do that we
need to head to a remote base on the
planets or cash the reason we're going
here is that according to Rex some of
the female Krogan survive malin's
experiments when the solarians heard of
this the Dallas sent in a team to take
them prisoner and they're being kept to
this base on circash as for who leaked
the info well the answer might actually
surprise you
all specimens are accounted for sir
Shepard excellent timing good to have
you here Morden is back and working with
the STG again this game is a bit of a
surprise because Morton was clearly in
favor of the genfage but as he'll
explain he's had a change of heart he
says that he's getting old but knows
that he's the best candidate for the job
but if someone else was leading the team
they could make a mistake and similar to
Thane he wants to do one last good thing
before he goes this may sound like he's
seeking atonement but I never saw it as
such Morton has always seen things
logically rather than emotionally he
still has his emotional moments like
when he condemned malin's testing
methods but most of the time he thinks
logically at the time he determined that
the best course of action for the Krogan
was to sterilize them and now he thinks
it's best that they're cured it's not
that he's sorry for what he did but he
realizes that this solution would be the
best for the Galaxy at this point in
time if Morton is dead though then a
solarian named Paddock Wix replaces him
this mission is a good example of the
opposite side of the spectrum instead of
Morden and Rex we have Paddock and Reeve
and while the story still works it just
feels much better with the original two
included that pretty much sums up most
of my thoughts on the main missions most
are either well done or passable knowing
what we know about Morton and Rex it
makes sense that Morton would be the
head researcher on the genophage and Rex
would want the genophage cured we've
only just been introduced to Paddock so
we don't really know what he wants it
never felt like Paddock really cared
about the project but rather the devs
needed someone to replace Morton so they
threw in a random solarion that acted
like him as for Reeve I think his ideals
make sense as they're consistent amongst
all Krogan but that's what made Rex
different he went against the status quo
to bring about change Reeve isn't
striving for change instead of the story
being about a Krogan who went against
his people to make sure they could live
again it's a story about one Krogan
leader who's just like the rest who had
happened to get lucky and be allied with
Shepard this debacle is what makes Mass
Effect 3 so hard to talk about because
having Reeve and Paddock in the story
really brings down the quality but that
seems to be intentional since the story
seemed to be designed with the other two
in mind it's another problem the team
would have to tackle and given how
Monumental the task is I'm willing to
give them a pass on a lot of this
because making sure each story is just
just as interesting while also removing
core characters from that story is hard
to do and like I said most of them are
either really well done or good enough
regardless of whether or not Morden or
Paddock is present though something is
wrong The Cure hasn't been successful
yet many of the female Krogan that were
fertile have died except for one more
than nicknamed Eve she is the last
fertile Krogan left at the facility
clearly she is of high importance and
Cerberus thinks so as well as they crash
the party and try to kill her while we
make a run for it we can see some of the
solarian experiments and it seems like
they were experimenting on varen and
even some yogg judging from the logs and
data pads left around the facility the
solarians were trying to domesticate or
uplift the odds that they could be
useful to them similar to what they did
with the Krogan
careful there goes the next Shadow
broker could have sworn he was muttering
to Sony the whole time not funny
assuming you make it out alive you
escort Eve back to the Normandy and get
a chance to talk with her Eve really
highlights something about the Mass
Effect series that is lacking and that's
a feminine perspective most of the
aliens we meet are male with the
exception of the asari talking with Eve
allows us to see another side of the
Krogan as we know the Krogan mostly
fight each other and see the women as
prized possessions and I've always
wondered what the women of the crow can
think about this and Eve was able to
communicate that to me Eve says that
when Clan warlock was trying to cure the
genophage the same Clan from Morton's
loyalty Mission she and some of the
other women volunteered Shepard
questions this because warlock is a
rival Clan Eve claims that rivalries are
a creation of the males and that's what
led to tachanka looking like a deserted
ruin furthermore Eve wants the women to
rule the Krogan again just like they did
back in the day this was the kind of
thing I've always wanted to hear from
the other races but this Trilogy never
gave it a thought we can meet two
solarian women throughout the trilogy
the new counselor and the dalatras both
of whom provide no insight into their
species history we also end up meeting
two targeted women as well and a couple
of DLCs and the same goes for them too
for the small amounts of info we have we
know that turian women served alongside
the men in the military and celerian
women were usually kept safe on their
homeworlds furthermore salerians don't
mate unless it's for reproduction and
even then they usually sign contracts
and pick people with the best Bloodlines
that they can get the most out of it
there was a whole side quest about this
in Mass Effect 2 on ilium I've always
wanted to know how the other gender
views the racist culture because it
allows us to learn more about them Mass
effect's World building has always been
something I've taken an interest in and
seeing Eve's perspective opened up my
eyes to a lot of this game's history I
just wish the same happened for the
other races too with Eve on the Normandy
morta can get working on a cure and
while we wait we can do some side
missions I was going to save these for
the side content section later but Mass
Effect 3 has a couple missions that are
technically side content but really
should be done right away we get these
missions from the Primark and from Rex
apparently Rex Von traces of the rack 9
near remote relay this is odd for both
playthroughs as in one we killed her but
in the other we told her to hide away
from the rest of the Galaxy but that
doesn't seem to be happening when we
arrive we see that the person leading
this company of Krogan is none other
than grunt if Grant is dead though it's
a Kroger named dag we and grunt split up
and find rachni but they seem to have
been reaperfied once we make it to the
bottom we realize that the original
rachni Queen is down here and has been
kept here by the Reapers if she died
back in Mass Effect 1 then it's a fake
cracked Knight queen that was made by
the Reapers both of them look identical
and were given the same options in bold
playthroughs spare or kill her doing
this provides us with a few options
which can get a bit complex basically if
we saved the queen before and then save
her again she gets added to our war
assets if we instead choose to leave her
then we get some of grunt's team as War
assets if it's the fake queen though
saving her gives us both grunt's team
and her as a war asset which he ends up
betraying you and you lose them killing
her though is the same as before grunt's
team is a war asset on paper it sounds
quite complex and to an extent it is but
it's this exact mechanic that keeps
bothering me Mass Effect ever since 2
always felt like the team went overboard
with certain parts of the game Mass
Effect 2 gave us 12 Companions and to
many that was a bit too much even though
I loved that game's companions 12 is a
lot to juggle at one time which is why
Mass Effect 3 dialed it back to seven in
Mass Effect 3 The Companions were
replaced with war assets just about
everything in this game contributes to
the war effort no matter how small it
may seem this Quest is supposed to be
one of the big options according to that
list earlier and yet not only are the
Queens exactly the same but your
decision also ends up being War assets
every single time it's the same exact
thing as the council similar design and
similar outcome I understand how
important the war assets are in this
game but we don't even get to see our
choices the recognize decision isn't
tangible it's just numbers on a screen
this is the last time we will ever see
the arachni queen and her species again
she was supposed to have one of the
biggest choices in Mass Effect 3 but all
she got was about 7 Minutes of screen
time across the trilogy it just feels
like a waste of time because this Choice
doesn't matter either like I said
technically it does matter but have
having all these decisions just become
War assets diminishes their impact
greatly because now it's not oh saving
the rachni queen changes this one part
of the mission which then leads to
another side objective it's now just
saving her ads 100 to the war asset
number and that is just not satisfying
to me the quest is also in the outlier
category when it comes to patching up
the story as I said most of these
missions are either well done or good
enough this is one of those missions
that just doesn't feel right without
grunt dag is likable enough since he has
the personality of a normal Krogan but
this final cutscene with him is just
bizarre with him involved if Shepard
saves the queen grunt fends off the rack
and I and it's a really touching scene
as it looks like runts going out in a
blaze of glory if he's loyal though then
he survives but it's still quite
gut-wrenching to watch this same exact
scene plays out with dag and it just
feels so out of place Grunt and Shepard
have history so having the mission play
out this way makes sense but dag is just
some guy we met on this Mission and the
music comes in like he's sacrificing his
life for a friend which is just odd
after finishing our mission with grunt
we can report back to the Normandy and
do Primark Victor's Mission apparently
his son is stranded on tachanka and
needs to be rescued after being asked
why he's on the Krogan Homeworld the
Primark says it's classified we learn
from his son though that there's a bomb
on tachanka that's about to go off
furthermore we also learn that it's not
only a turian bomb but that Cerberus is
the one who's trying to blow it up this
Mission isn't too important regarding
story plots but it does highlight the
game's commitment to urgency we'll see
more examples of this in the side
content section but Mass Effect 3
handles urgency pretty well
urgency is a difficult topic to talk
about and one I personally hate
discussing it's hard to create a sense
of urgency in a game like a mass effect
where the player can go wherever they
want and do whatever side missions they
want cyberpunk got criticism for this
because in that game the main character
has about three weeks to live but you
can wait over three weeks in game and
nothing happens some thought that
cyberpunk had no urgency because of this
which confused me because if the game
only gave us three in-game weeks to
finish the story then it would suck
that's why I only look at the main
missions themselves to see if it fits
there is currently a war going on in
Mass Effect 3 so Shepard shouldn't be
delaying the mission to go dance on the
Citadel but BioWare knew this and took
it even further than I thought they
would as not only do the main quests
keep that sense of urgency but so do the
side quests all the main missions make
sense and I'll take into account the
reaper threat it feels like there's
never any downtime during the missions
because you're constantly going from one
task to the next because people's lives
are on the line even the two missions we
just talked about uphold this idea
because the rack and I'm making a move
on the Galaxy is strange and is
definitely something we should check out
and rescuing the Primark Sun at first
might not seem important but it could
possibly give us an upper hand as he
would owe us a favor plus it worked out
anyway since we discovered there's an
active bomb on the planet all of the
main missions and just about every side
mission has a sense of urgency and I'm
really glad BioWare recognized this when
creating them now that both missions are
finished though we can finally cure the
genif age but doing that is easier said
than done according to Morton there's a
building called the Shroud that protects
the chanca from solar radiation Morton
believes that that in theory they could
disperse the Cure from the Shroud
allowing it to kill the planet's
inhabitants of the disease to do that
though they're going to need to go
through a giant Reaper which is
currently destroying the planet the plan
is to attack from the air and the ground
at the same times that we can draw its
attention away from the Shroud it sounds
like a decent enough plan but once we
land on tachanka Reef starts an argument
with Rex this is another reason why Rex
being alive is a lot better than having
him dead as we know from Mass Effect 2
Reeve operates like a normal Krogan but
Rex is different it creates this tense
bout between two brutes as they have
different ideals and different ways of
upholding those ideals but if Rex is
dead it's not Rex vs Reeve it's re vs
jorgal jurgel is a new character but he
acts like re which is why the story
takes a hit since it's just two
Meatheads having a dick measuring
contest instead of a Krogan who goes
against the status quo versus the one
who's stuck in his ways after this the
team will continue on and do you
remember when I said that taking down a
Reaper was going to be tough and that
the methods were either going to be
overwhelming power or something
unconventional well this is exactly that
because if we can ring the Hammers here
on tachanka we can summon kalros the
mother of all thresherma's and it
actually works ringing the hammer
summons Kal Ross who kills the reaper
without much effort oddly enough around
this time Rex daps Shepherd up and tells
him that no matter what happens Shepard
will always be known as a hero to the
people of tachanka and a paragon
interrupt occurs which I think is the
first time this occurs in the main story
Mass Effect 3 has changed the morality
system a bit morality is now named
reputation this has an effect on the
game that I didn't notice until much
later the best example is right at the
end of the game where Shepard meets The
elusive man similar to saren we can
force The elusive man to take his own
life of our speech checks are high
enough but in that game we only had
access to one side of the dialogue
because our Shepherd was a full Paragon
in Mass Effect 3 though this changes
it's not based on how much Paragon or
Renegade you have but how much of both
you have our Paragon Shepherd as you
would expect has a lot of Paragon and
not a lot of renegade yet they can still
choose the Renegade option because their
overall reputation is extremely high on
our Renegade Shepherd though we have
lots of renegade but can choose the
dialog option because our overall
reputation is too low I honestly really
like this system a lot and it's probably
the best version of the morality system
so far in the series because you weren't
locked out of a specific dialogue just
because you're stuck with one alignment
it allows the player to play how they
want and not how they should
slight detour aside once Rex and Shepard
shake hands they go their separate ways
and attempt to ring the Hammers once cow
Ross's summon Shepard can then meet with
Morton who says that the device must be
fired manually which means for Morton
this is a one-way trip he is at the end
of his life as he said and dying here is
probably the best way for him to go you
can however sabotage this whole ordeal
if you want to before the tuchanka
mission the dalatras meets and asks if
you can sabotage the cures that the
Krogan believed that they're cured this
would allow us to win over the Krogan
just long enough for them to help out
palavan so the turians can send their
troops to Earth I clearly didn't kill
Morden nor do I want to as he said the
genifade needs to be cured now and if he
deems it to be the time then it's time
Morden then ascends the Shroud and sings
the same song he sang back in Mass
Effect 2 which is a nice call back to
that scene Morden is still one of my
favorite characters in Mass Effect and
seeing him go is sad but his death is
not wasted he lived a fulfilling life
and having his legacy be known as the
doctor who cured the Krogan is quite the
title to have as for Paddock though I
shot him right away oh also because I
didn't have malin's research in the
Renegade playthrough Eve actually died
so not only did the Krogan not get cured
but the last fertile female is dead as
well so the Krogan are truly doomed in
that playthrough finishing this Mission
though concludes the First Act of Mass
Effect 3 and so far the story has been
on a roll the prologue starts off really
strong with the return of the Reapers
and the destruction of Earth and act 1
continues the intensity by having us
cure the genophage something that has
been a core of mass effects history
since the game's Inception and act 2 is
about to get even more intense as we're
tasked with solving the war between the
Geth and the quarians something that's
been going on for over 300 years but
before we do that though we have two
things to handle first we received
information that there is a prothean
artifact on Eden Prime and that udina is
moving vast amounts of money on the
Citadel which is something he hasn't
done before both of these seem pretty
low priority given the war going on and
all but both of these missions are
actually very important if we go back to
Eden Prime the same place we visited all
the way back in Mass Effect 1 will
uncover a pod with an alien in it this
alien's name is javik and he is a
prothean the only one of his kind the
protheans if you remember are one of the
most important races in the series as
they were wiped out 50 000 years ago and
it's because of their Advanced Tech and
impressive tactics that we were able to
find the plans for The Crucible and
discover vigil back on ilos so it's
thanks to the protheans that we were
able to stop Sovereign from summoning
the Reapers all those years ago even if
you were never told that javik was a
prothean you could easily infer that
this was the case since the collectors
have a similar design javik is clearly
confused concerned dazed and probably a
dozen other adjectives seeing as he was
frozen for over 50 000 years but he
manages to calm himself down while
trying to unlock javik's pod we can peer
into his history thanks to Shepard
getting that Cipher back in Mass Effect
1. we can see that the protheans have
advanced technology and even biotic
abilities it also seems like they too
were overrun by the Reaper's
overwhelming power the plan just like
the researchers on iOS was to put
themselves into cryo sleep until the
next civilization comes by and opens the
pods sadly this took longer than
intended and power had to be conserved
in moves that the pods could still Opera
rate this meant taking power from other
pods which is why javik is the only one
alive being revived after 50 000 years
and being told that not only are you the
only prothean left but that the reapers
are back and are still winning is a lot
to take in it also doesn't help that to
javik all the races in the Galaxy are
still considered primitive to him
because well let's be honest with
ourselves no one has created anything
like the beacon on Eden Prime so this
cycle is way behind in technology this
exact sentiment has been a growing
concern for many in the galaxy and
rightfully so if the protheans couldn't
defeat the Reapers what makes you think
that we will that's what makes the story
of Mass Effect 3 so great because
Shepard is changing the world and doing
things no one has done before javik says
that the protheans fought alone because
the Galaxy couldn't work together in his
cycle but in our cycle we can see that
this has changed so far we've gotten the
Krogan turian and solarians to join
humanity and now it's time to get the
Geth and the quarians but as I said
we'll have to deal with udina first I'll
talk about javik a bit more when we get
to our final companion which is coming
up in a few moments but to get there
we'll have to stop a coup from happening
and depending on our actions we might
end up actually losing a companion in
the process as we talked about earlier
udina is apparently moving large sums of
money around which is concerning the
salarian council and he wants us to
check it out good thing we did because
we discovered it was more than just
money laundering Houdini is working with
Cerberus to Stage a coup on the Citadel
Cerberus has managed to overwhelm c-seek
so it's up to us to stop him and it's
here where we get introduced to Kai Lang
I do not like Kai link and that probably
won't come as a surprise a lot of my
complaints stem from his first
impression first impressions are
important in any context this first
interaction will dictate how we judge a
character going forward sometimes it's
used as a way to subvert expectations or
allow for a character to grow like with
Miranda who was nicknamed ice queen but
ends up becoming a lot more personable
when you speak to her Kai Lang seems to
be an assassin and seeing as he's using
a sword in a Sci-Fi game we can assume
he has some amount of skill with such a
weapon not even Thane used bladed
weapons and he also was an assassin as
he talks about killing some someone with
a sniper rifle speaking of thane he
comes in to save the solarian counselor
this isn't as jarring as it looks as you
can meet him at the hospital a few times
it's mostly just to catch up and see
what he's been up to though the part
that is jarring though is that Thane
almost beats him hermar talks with Thane
we can see that he is just waiting for
his time to pass the capital syndrome
that has been affecting him since the
last game is still progressing and we
know from the layer of Shadow broker
dossiers that Thane was instructed to
rest and not do any strenuous activity
or he could essentially die faster
so Thane is a terminally ill Doral with
some type of asthma since Capital
syndrome affects his lungs yet not only
did he keep up with Kai Lang he almost
beat him kailang barely manages to
escape thanks to him stabbing Thane with
his sword than will pull through so he's
not dead yet but this fight has sealed
his fate the problem with this fight is
that from this first impression you
don't get the sense that Kai Lang is a
great assassin but rather an incompetent
one he comes off as inexperienced and in
way over his head and I can't tell if
this was supposed to be intentional some
of the dialogue seems to point towards
Kai Lang being designed by the writers
as an assassin who thinks he's the best
but then other dialogue says he's the
best
should be embarrassed
a terminally El Doral managed to stop
him from reaching his Target
I'll pass the word along
what your assassin
I'll have I can send you my reports on
him
I take it you two have met
Kaylee Sanders and I had a share of
Runnings with him I shot him in both
legs once thought that might be the end
of him but he showed up again on Omega
even stronger elusive man patch him up
that'd be my guess
given what they were able to do with you
and Grayson
it's a safe bet Lang's even more
dangerous now even if Kai Lang was meant
to be a terrible assassin that still
wouldn't remedy the problem since he
seems to stop us at every turn Kai Lang
is here during the Citadel Mission which
goes nowhere as all he does is stab
Thane and then destroy our car he then
arrives on thessia a bit later for a
lukewarm boss fight since he's designed
not to die and then magically overpowers
the team even if you were destroying him
the entire fight this then all
culminates at the Cerberus headquarters
where you can actually kill him but the
fight is okay at best it's quite easy to
defeat Kai Lang and that's a real issue
because BioWare is capable of making a
villain that matches their strength both
of the fights with sarin were quite
tough you fought him in small rooms with
limited cover and you had to put
hundreds of rounds into him while
difficulty is always going to be
subjective at least on normal difficulty
his large health and deadly abilities
complemented his role as the main
villain obviously Kai Lang isn't the
main villain of the game but he is a
looming threat one that doesn't live up
to the role at any point in the story he
also suffers from having the most
annoying per personality I have ever
seen Kai Lang is basically a weeb ninja
he uses a physical sword in the Mass
Effect universe and went outnumbered
three to one his first line of dialogue
is ha now it's fun I was half expecting
him to say something like good try
Shepard but that was only 10 of my power
you haven't even seen my final form yet
he also taunts you via email after you
encounter him on vesia and just read
this what kind of Light Yagami ass
speech is this
however there is still one way we can
redeem him for probably the first time
all game the Renegade option actually
has the better story if Thane is dead
captain kirihi from vermeier replaces
him but since both are dead in that
playthrough that means Kai Lang has no
one standing in his way furthermore when
we reach udina later he shows fabricated
footage of Shepard shooting the
counselor this would easily make the
player furious at Kai Lang for setting
them up like that and it would continue
to break the relationship between the
council and Shepard one that was
admittedly quite broken already as a
whole I think kailang as a concept is
great this assassin that is constantly
stalking Shepard and foiling his plans
but he suffers from having very little
interaction with the player and anytime
he does interact with them he always
seems to come out on top no matter the
context once we make it through a few
gameplay Arenas we'll come to the top
floor where udina and the other
counselors are and protecting them is
Ashley depending on our actions here and
some choices before this Ashley may not
make it out of here alive Ashley still
believes that Shepard is working with
Cerberus and is willing to shoot us if
we don't comply this either ends with
actually getting shot and dying or
turning on udina and siding with us it's
quite infuriating that Ashley still
won't believe us but I like how past
choices can affect this as Romancing her
in Mass Effect 1 adds points but
cheating on her in Mass Effect 2 takes
away points no matter what happens
though udina is shot and killed for his
actions and the council finally takes a
liking to us still surprised it took
this long for that to happen though
after this though we are gonna have to
say goodbye to Thane this was quite
expected seeing as he took a sword to
the stomach and the capital syndrome was
already progressing at a fast rate this
just accelerated the process the whole
scene though is really sweet and well
done as kolyat is here and you can join
him in saying some prayers this
surprises Thane as these are prayers
from religions that many Israel don't
believe in anymore than is happy to see
that his son is not going down the path
he took and is being a better person the
prayer that the three recite though was
not for Thane but actually for Shepard
Thane always prayed after a kills that
he was absolved of his sins and Shepard
questioned this because Thane wasn't
killing someone because a contract said
so he tried to attack Kai Lang because
he wanted to he was a hero in that
moment not an assassin which is where
koliat reveals that this prayer was for
Shepard and his journey even in his
final moments Thane wanted to make sure
Shepard was okay and that his journey
was free of Despair and harm that killed
me Thane was easily one of the most
likable and unique Companions of Mass
Effect 2 and seeing his Devotion to
Shepard and his cause through this was
gut wrenching BioWare really wanted to
get the tears flowing in this entry as
so far Morton and Thane have died for us
so that we can complete our mission this
connects to a few conversations that
we'll have with some of the crew because
throughout this whole trilogy Shepard
has gone from one thing to the next and
hasn't really had a chance to sit down
even though he had a six-month break in
between games the threat of the Reapers
is still out there and he can't rest
until this war is done so it's no wonder
that this war is still affecting him all
this death and loss that he's experience
is something no one should go through
once we finish up with Thane and coyot
we can meet with Ashley or Kaden and
talk to them about what just happened
you can also ask them to join your team
again or tell them that they are best
suited under Admiral hackett's
leadership it's minor but I like the
small degree of choice we're given here
because if you really don't like them
given their opinions of you on Horizon
and Mars you can just essentially tell
them to kick rocks and never return
losing a companion hurts but I'm happy
that BioWare is finally committing to
the idea that companions don't have plot
armor and can leave the team if certain
conditions arise
after this brief intermission though
we're able to start act 2. Admiral
Hackett says that the Italian support
ships they send are being stretched thin
so we need more fleets but lucky for us
the Koreans are willing to talk as they
too have their own problems we then meet
with the Corian Admirals who are the
same ones from the last game Admirals
Ron Han Garrell chorus Zen and their new
Ambassador talizora Tali will join us
for most of these missions as well but
if she is dead then her and Admiral Ron
will take her place tally is an admiral
because she's an expert on the Geth and
because her dad used to occupy the other
Admiral spot but since he died in tali's
loyalty mission that spot was left open
however despite there being five
Admirals the quarians are more divided
than ever we saw a bit of this back in
Mass Effect 2 but just as a refresher
the Admirals have different feelings on
the Geth and whether or not the Corian
should go to war with them Avril
hangarol is the leader of the heavy
Fleet and he is in favor of reclaiming
ranok and going to war with the Geth
Admiral Zen leader of these Special
Projects division has always been in
favor of defeating the Geth because she
still sees them as machines that need to
be controlled Emerald chorus leader of
the civilian fleet was labeled a
gethopologist in the last game because
he believes that the Geth deserve
rannock as their sentient creatures and
should not have been fought Admiral Ron
is the leader of the patrol Fleet and
while she doesn't outright take a side
she does seem to be in favor of War as
she does help some of the Admirals by
providing provisional support for them
and Tali is possibly indecisive
depending on whether or not she talked
with Legion back in Mass Effect 2.
speaking of Legion we'll end up meeting
him very soon as when we meet with the
Admirals they ask us to take out a Geth
Dreadnought that is currently pounding
their forces the one who is controlling
it is Legion but not of his own volition
after Legion left the Normandy and went
back to the Geth they created a mega
server that houses all their memories
and data set the gath no longer had to
be isolated from each other right after
its construction though the quarines
attacked so they had to defend
themselves and their server this caused
them to panic because the Geth operate
better in groups as we know from Mass
Effect 1 the Geth gets smarter when
there are more of them around so when
they started dying their intelligence
got worse
what made the guest desperate enough to
work for the Reapers yes imagine that
for every one of your people lost on
Earth your own intelligence death
the Creator's attack narrowed the
death's perspective self-preservation
took precedence you were afraid you'd be
wiped out
we do not experience fear as you would
but we have no desire to be exterminated
even if the Reapers cost the guest free
will
that is evidently an acceptable trade
so the Guth were basically doomed to die
until the Reapers offered to help them
they didn't want to Ally with the
Reapers but they determined that it was
the only choice they only joined them
because they wanted to live like I said
just a second ago as we know from the
previous games due to how the death were
made the more there are the smarter they
get well with the reaper upgrades this
is no longer needed they are essentially
as strong as they can be without the
need for each other from here though
we're tasked with doing two different
side missions similar to act one the
first is that the Geth of a planetary
defense cannon on ranok the former
quarian Homeworld an admiral course
decided to sacrifice his own ship in
order to blow it up thankfully he
survived the crash but now we have to
rescue him this sounds like a waste of
time but Admiral chorus dying would be a
huge blow to morale and defenses for a
plethora of reasons the corians decided
to convert all their ships into
dreadnoughts even the civilian ones
which admittedly is kind of impressive
the issue though is that the civilian
fleachers the same ideals as chorus so
not only is their ship being turned into
a target for the guests but they're also
forced to fight an enemy they didn't
want to fight in the first place Admiral
chorus dying in a war that he didn't
want to be a part of would easily piss
off the rest of the civilian Fleet and
make their final push onto ranac much
harder the mission goes just about how
you would expect but I do love this one
encounter with a Dorn Hots according
that was a part of the civilian Fleet he
tells us how we need to find the Admiral
because the civilian Fleet never wanted
this war and if anyone is going to be
able to get them out alive it's him
Dorne also says though that he's never
shot a gun before and now he's bleeding
on the ground this could not only show
how Reckless chorus is by just crashing
onto a planet with civilians aboard but
also just how warped accordions have
become due to this war with The Gap
they're now sending civilians Into The
Fray even if they've never shot a gun
before as for Legion he says that there
are Geth fighter squads that plan to
attack the quarians and will likely
succeed if not stopped the problem
though is that we can't just blow up
their server or stop their ships we have
to go inside the Geth consensus and take
them out that way so Shepard gets sent
inside and has to shoot these yellow
strands to stop the Geth this isn't
normally how it looks though because
Legion is creating an environment that
is familiar to Shepard which is why
we're shooting at these strands of code
since technically all of this is being
handled digitally inside the server we
can see some of the memories of the Geth
and see how poorly they were treated by
the corians once they started to gain
sentience I honestly find it quite hard
to talk about the Geth and quarian War
because to me I see both sides of the
argument accidentally creating a
sentient AI is scary and should probably
be shut down immediately but the guests
were well within their rights to fight
back regardless though you'll likely
have noticed that the missions have
changed whereas act 1's missions were
just about helping the Krogan and
turians with their problems act 2's
Mission showed the player a different
side of each faction Mass Effect 3
really wants you to see the horrors of
this war and all the people who are
involved in it and then force you to
make a choice should the Geth or
accordions win the war or should they
broker piece before we make that
decision though we have to deal with
another Reaper this one dies in a more
conventional way through overwhelming
power but we do have to get up close to
it so we can use the targeting laser
right before it dies we can talk to it
and all it really says is that they
represent order and the world represents
chaos when Shepherd tells it that they
deserve an answer all it says is that
it's something they can't come
comprehend afterwards is where we get to
make our choice Legion says that the
Geth are no longer under the control of
the Reapers but Legion asks Shepard if
they deserve death since the Admiral
plans do fire on the gath now that their
ships lay dormant in space Legion
suggests that he upload the reaper code
to the guests that they can gain the
sentience and power that they had while
under Reaper control but without the
Reapers actually controlling them this
is where we have to decide the fate of
an entire race if we side with Legion
the Geth upload their code and attack
the quarians wiping them out for good
Tali will also kill herself since all
her people are now dead if we side with
the quarians then Legion will attack but
not before being shot by Tali or Admiral
Ron however it is possible to get the
best of both worlds and for the first
time in 300 years create peace between
these two groups similar to the
encounter with Ashley some of our
decisions are part of a point system
some of these are present in Mass Effect
3 such as saving Admiral chorus but most
of these are in Mass Effect 2.
destroying instead of rewriting the
guests making sure Tali isn't exiled in
her loyalty Mission and making sure the
two come to an agreement during their
confrontation are critical to making
sure this ending goes well these are the
kinds of choices I was hoping for in
Mass Effect something that may seem
insignificant now but becomes very
important later is something I wanted to
see from this series because it not only
makes achieving a good ending harder but
also makes the playthroughs more unique
not everyone is going to come out of
this Mission with the same ending and
that's the kind of dramatic storytelling
I was hoping for the fight between the
Geth and the quarians has been relevant
in every game and all of our choices all
culminate in the final decision if you
took a liking to the Koreans through
Tali you might be more inclined to side
with the quarians furthermore seeing how
the Geth operated in Mass Effect 1 may
have caused you to dislike them from the
get-go but interacting with the corians
may have also prompted a different
reaction one that's not as pleasant
seeing the civilians be thrown into a
war they never wanted while also being
ordered around by four Admirals that
can't even agree with each other might
make siding with the quarians a
difficult Choice the war is a Trilogy
long issue and getting that good ending
is difficult so it forces a lot of
players to make an actual Choice one
that is quite hard to make regardless of
our decision though Legion will either
die by force or through sacrifice as his
death gave the rest of the Geth
intelligence before dying though Tali
brings up the question that started the
war in the first place
do you remember the question that caused
the creators to attack us talisora
does this unit have a soul
Shepherd Commander I must go to them
I am
I'm sorry
it's the only way
Legion
the answer to your question
was yes
thank you
just like the Gen of age it was only a
matter of time until the situation was
put to rest and it sits alongside the
rack and I queen as one of my favorite
questions Mass Effect poses to the
player should something that wasn't
sentient but now is be granted the same
rights as all other sentient life or
should it remain a robotic servant it's
a philosophical question so ultimately
it's not going to have a proper answer
but that's the point you take in
everything you've experienced across all
three games then figure out where you
stand this is your story after all
with the centuries long war finally put
to an end we can move on to the second
half of Act 2 but since Tali has joined
our party that means we've gotten all of
our companions so let's quickly talk
about our new members and also see what
our old cast has been up to the first
person we end up meeting is the vermeyer
Survivor I mentioned how I wasn't a big
fan of Ashley and Kaden in Mass Effect 2
because they weren't two separate people
but just some entity called the vermeier
Survivor a person who has been on the
base of Horizon and despises Shepard for
working with Cerberus Mass Effect 3
continues this sadly as the two are
always in the same place the only major
difference is their personal dialogue
and side mission Mass Effect 3 doesn't
really place a whole lot of priority on
the companions this time around whereas
Mass Effect 2 had two-thirds of the game
dedicated to their Recruitment and
loyalty missions this fits with the
overall plot of the game as we aren't
creating a small team but rather an army
as such the crew doesn't have any
loyalty missions and we can't really
talk with them at least not in the
traditional sense most of the dialogue
starts with us going up to them and
pressing the interact button which
prompts them to say a line or two of
dialogue about the mission for example
after rescuing Eve if you talk to Garris
he'll comment on her strength and
courage given all she's gone through
this is the same for all the crews
who'll end up getting into a routine of
doing a main mission then circling the
Normandy to hear everyone's opinions
this however can get a bit tedious at
times especially when they decide to
leave their post as the crew can move
floors and go somewhere else but this
was a great addition to the game as it
makes things feel more alive like the
crew has a functional social life and
isn't just sitting in the rooms waiting
for Shepard to talk to them furthermore
each companion will also ask to meet on
the Citadel when you have free time
which allows you to talk to them more or
possibly continue a romance if
applicable The Citadel mission is really
where Ashley and Cadence start to differ
everything up until the Citadel attack
is pretty much the same both of them
were attacked and hospitalized and then
after some time got a recommendation
from udina to join the specters they
then joined and helped guard the council
from you until they either died or were
convinced to stand down assuming you
allow them to join you though you can
visit them on the Normandy and for their
side mission Cadence is more about
relaxation as he's initially worried
about his mom who's alone at home thanks
to his dad serving in the war and being
M.I.A if you offer some encouraging
words you can also join him on the
Citadel for some lunch Kaden claims that
he needed to have a sanity check which
is why he came to the cafe this is where
you can continue your romance with him
if he wants but if not the two of you
just continue eating as for Ashley she's
initially worried for her sister because
her husband was called back into the
service due to the reaper War it is
discovered later though that her husband
was eventually killed in action as part
of her side mission you can join her and
her sister and offer your sympathies
while visiting the memorial wall on the
Citadel overall they aren't amazing
missions but ice assume that if you like
Ashley and Kaden then you might like
these missions as well besides those
missions though not much else really
happens with Kaden Ashley however goes
through a bit of an arc in Mass Effect 1
she was very much against working with
aliens and U.S Shepard couldn't condemn
her for thinking this way if he wanted
to in Mass Effect 3 though it seems like
she's been more accepting of the crew as
she offers to talk to Liara after the
mission on desio which will make more
sense when we get to that mission and if
Tali dies in The rannock Mission she'll
ask Shepard to leave her alone for a bit
since Tali was like a sister to her I
think my only complaint with this is
that I wish more of it was forced onto
the player and not just hidden behind
some small bit of dialogue because it's
very easy to miss these talks and if you
don't remember to meet with her you'll
just go on thinking she hasn't changed
when she actually has overall though I
do like her character Arc and it's also
the main reason why I came to another
conclusion it really feels like Ashley
was the Canon choice for this series I
know talking about canonicity is
pointless since it's your story but
Ashley not only has a different
personality but an arc and a complete
makeover even if Ashley the Canon Choice
isn't true it's very obvious that she
got more attention than Kaden I said
that I liked Kaden in Mass Effect one
more and that's still true as I really
like his backstory but if we're talking
about the whole trilogy Ashley clearly
wins because Kaden doesn't change now
you don't need to make a character
change all the time in order for them to
be considered likable but being stagnant
is a problem a great example is our next
companion Garris Garris has always been
fighting Justice that part of him has
never changed but the ways he went about
doing it though are what makes his story
interesting because he went to Great
Lengths in order to achieve his goal he
went from fighting with Commander
Shepard to being a vigilante that had
three of omega's top gangs fighting
against him his core ideals had never
changed but the ways he went about doing
them did after fighting the collectors
Garris worked with some of the Terrian
military and got his own Reaper task
force which to him is not something he
really wanted since he's not exactly an
expert on the Reapers he knows about as
much as anyone else does with the only
difference being that he's actually
survived a fight with one which I guess
given the circumstances is a lot better
than anyone else this job really weighs
down on him though since he like many of
the top officials are in charge of
millions of people's lives that's a lot
of pressure for someone who's been a
vigilante for a few years and only
really followed the rules in csec in
those days crimes weren't galaxy-wide
attacks and the only people he had to
worry about was his Squad back in Omega
but that's where the brotherly love
comes in as him and Shepard are both
struggling over the loss of their people
but they always seem to pick each other
up when they need it which is why his
side mission felt special as it was the
first time the two could just relax
which really cements their friendship
once Garris joins the crew he gets to
work on calibrating like he usually does
but will ask you to join him on the
Citadel originally I thought this would
involve drinking and I guess I was half
right as Garris takes us to a restricted
area and we start shooting drinks with
sniper rifles the phrase brother from
another mother fits these two perfectly
they've gone through hell and back twice
now and now it's about to be their third
however one sad detail I noticed during
the palavan mission is when James asked
about garris's family on palaven and he
said he had a dad and sister but in the
layer of the Shadow broker there's a
conversation between him and his sister
about their mother it seems like their
mom had some sort of terminal illness
and the money the two had was not going
to be enough to pay for the procedures
given that he doesn't mention her we can
assume that she passed away in between
games
despite how consistent Garris has been
throughout the series he's not the only
one that's shown up multiple times the
other two veteran companions are Liara
and Tali Liara as we know is the new
Shadow broker this seems to be Canon as
if he didn't do the DLC it's one that
she hired a ton of mercs to help instead
Liara has a lot more power now which
means she can now feel like a valuable
asset to the team which was one thing
that was bringing her down during that
DLC and she ends up using some of that
power to create a backup plan at some
point later in the game she'll come to
Shepard's cabin with a gift this box is
a time capsule that she plans to make
with the hope that if they fail other
civilizations will find it it seems to
have plans for The Crucible as well as
any knowledge they have gained in the
Reapers up until this point but Lira
also wanted to add one more thing which
is a description of Shepard we are the
one who's made the most progress so far
so it makes sense that we're a part of
the Time Capsule whatever you choose to
say though ultimately doesn't matter but
this interaction is nice as it shows
that she's trying to consider all
possible options clearly the end of the
world is troubling her but it doesn't
seem to be the only thing troubling her
as she seems to have a not so great
relationship with her father that of
course being matriarch athita who we
first met back on ilium we had a brief
tease of this back in the lair of the
Shadow broker where we could find a
video of The Matriarch holding a picture
of Liara but that's about it you can
talk to her at the bar on the Citadel
and through some convincing can make
liar reconnect with her apparently she's
been keeping tabs on the r and has even
prevented a few hits on her
besides that though we can find out that
one of the matriarch's parents or
liara's grandparents was a Krogan which
means that makes Liara a quarter Krogan
the rest of the dialogue isn't too
important but it is nice to hear what
the two have to say as they catch up in
chat
foreign
I have never wanted to headbutt anything
really not even a little bit
come on I do not headbutt people as for
tally well most of her time in between
games was covered in the Act 2 Section
which that she left to go join the fleet
and then took up an admiral position
since she's an expert on the get not
much has happened since then so there
isn't much to say but there are two
things I found rather interesting
firstly if you romance College will give
you a picture of herself with her mask
off this was changing the legendary
edition and I'm definitely a fan of the
changes it looks more authentic the
other though is after a future mission
where we rate a place called sanctuary
in that mission we'll meet with Miranda
and her father after that mission though
we'll find Tali drinking by the bar
tally has decided to make a toast of
Miranda because she was able to stand up
to her father the reason why no one is
joining her is because this is something
tally struggles with she spends a lot of
her life trying to live up to him and
doing what he wanted her to do this
connects to her loyalty Mission which is
something I had mistakenly
misinterpreted I had originally thought
that her thank you at the end of the
scene was genuine but according to some
comments it was actually supposed to be
sarcastic thank you by the way for those
that corrected me on this because it
makes way more sense when combined with
this interaction
triple filled third then introduced into
the suit through an emergency induction
important
that's a straw tally
emergency
induction Port our final old crew member
is Edie she's still the ship's AI but
she's now taken on a mobile platform and
Joker is more than happy with the
decision Joker in Edie's relationship is
quite an important one as it's a
synthetic AI dating an organic human
this is unheard of since most AI have a
ton of blockages preventing them from
Gaining intelligence and sentience which
is what Edie used to be back in Mass
Effect 2 but since Joker overrode those
systems and the collectors attacked the
Normandy she is now completely sentient
what Edie is unfamiliar with though is
how this way of thinking works so she
does the typical synthetic thing and
looks at things from a more logical
perspective over time though we can see
her try to be more organic like instead
of saying Joker is smiling and laughing
at a higher rate than usual she'll
correct her statement and say that joker
is happier the first sentence sounds
like she's reading a stat sheet however
Edie can sometimes be really annoying to
talk to like when she tries to say a
joke at the most inopportune of times
but I don't think this is a writing
mistake EDS trying to be more human now
that she has free will but she misses
the mark sometimes and doesn't
understand the context that's why she
asks us a lot of questions but one
question I've always had for Edie though
is where she came from thankfully I got
that answer this isn't found until later
when we raid cerberus's headquarters but
has discovered that the AI we found on
the moon back in Mass Effect 1 was
partially Edie Cerberus took that Ai and
enhanced it with some Reaper technology
which gave birth to Edie we can have a
brief talk with her about that
experiment and Mass Effect 2 I believe
in which he says that it was cerberus's
attempt to create controllable AI but as
we saw that didn't really work overall
Edie was really Pleasant to talk to now
that she has free will as a lot of her
questions were very philosophical and
even if they were hard to answer they
were at least interesting to think about
with the old companions out of the way
though we can now talk about our two
remaining cast members javik and James
javik as we discussed earlier is a
prothian and according to him the
prothean people had assigned avatars to
each other these are traits that the
protheans embodied like bravery and
strength javix was vengeance he is the
anger of his people who demand that
blood be paid for blood and his only
purpose in life is to now defeat the
Reapers traffic is very dedicated to his
mission which makes sense given that
he's seen his entire population
disappear thanks to the Reapers which is
why he helps Commander Shepard is that
you share a common goal when we talk
with javik we get a bit more insight
into his people and his own abilities
according to javik the reason The
Crucible failed during his cycle was
that a splinter group thought that they
could control the reaper so they went
against everyone javik learned though
that these people were indoctrinated and
actually working for the Reapers hmm
definitely not foreshadowing anything
javik also repeatedly states that all
the Galaxy's races are primitive which
once again makes sense when you consider
the prothean technology but it's more
than just Tech prothians have the
ability to for a lack of a better word
feel a person or feel a room when we
first talk with javik down here in the
cargo bay he says that he feels the
anger of an individual in here this room
used to belong to grunt so he feels the
traces that grunt Left Behind he'd also
communicate memories to Shepard just
like how the beacon communicated those
memories to him back in Mass Effect 1.
also tends to offer a different
perspective on things as most of his
dialogue is blunt and pragmatic for
example during Act 2 with the Geth when
Legion comes on board the first thing
javik says is to take that thing and
space it out the airlock Shepard of
course is more than willing to work with
new races whereas javik is not he knows
the pain that the Reapers inflict and is
not willing to compromise on anything
that gets in his way for javik's side
mission we can take him to the Citadel
which was only a place of dreams for him
since the Reapers had already taken it
over by the time he was born jevik ends
up giving a rousing speech to some of
the people here and we can learn that
the protheans were like Gods to everyone
as they saw the races grow over time
javik remembers back when the humans
were just cavemen and is surprised that
not only can the asari right now but
that the solarians were even able to
evolve at all since they mostly just
licked their eyes constantly his people
were kind of like protectors in a sense
but I used that term loosely since they
mainly protected Races they thought had
the most potential but not potential to
evolve or Thrive or anything like that
but potential to join them as every race
was given a choice of joining the
protheans are dying I think out of all
the crew javik is my favorite in Mass
Effect 3. he has a different opinion on
certain topics that I'm always
interested to listen to and the fact
that he's a protheon also helps out as
well
that this war will end with your honor
intact
I do
stand in the ashes of a trillion dead
souls and ask the ghosts if honor
matters
this silence is your answer
our final companion though is James Vega
and honestly I feel so bad for James he
might have gotten the shortest stick out
of all the companions 5 out of these
seven companions in this list are old
members some as old as the first game so
we're already familiar with them and
have created a bond together the only
two people that aren't old are javik and
James and javix aprofian James also has
a typical human military background so
it's not too interesting but there is
one part that sticks out James served
under an officer Tony for a bit but he
and the rest of his crew died during a
collector attack James decided that the
mission was more important than the
lives of his Squad because the data they
found could have been critical to
stopping the collectors I say could have
though because Shepard already took care
of the collectors without that data so
James's Squad died for nothing Shepard
grills him a bit on this by asking if
this is why he was so reckless on Mars
and whether or not he even cares to live
or die anymore it does seem like James
is upset at his decision but recognizes
that he wouldn't have known about
Shepard in the crew so he made the right
choice at the time with the limited
knowledge he had after some time though
Shepard will get a call from James who
asked for a private conversation
apparently James has been nominated for
the N7 training which is the same thing
Shepard went through before the events
of the series he's confused by this
though since his past mission was a
total failure so he doesn't really see
himself as worthy you can convince him
to do it anyway which he's been getting
an N7 tattoo to commemorate the occasion
besides that though most of James's
discussions are quite mundane but I
really find that he shines through
gameplay thanks to me having three
companions for my whole Renegade
playthrough I was forced to use James
for most of the missions and it's here
where he starts to grow a personality
he's kind of like this dumb Meathead guy
and some of his dialogue is just such a
treat to listen to
him
hacking and security
nice to meet you Sparks Sparks yeah
you've got lights in your
uh
and you're kind of small and jumpy
it just came out
if you say so
James get on it
uh text not my specialty but I'll pull a
few wires see what comes out
as you can tell from the length of this
section though Mass Effect 3 really
didn't put a lot of effort into the
companions as opposed to Mass Effect 2
but this fits given the current
objective of the game plus more than
half the cast are older members all five
of whom were literally in the previous
game so it's not like there was much to
talk about since it's only been six
months that's why Mass Effect 2's
attempt to change their stories was
commendable two years had passed the
Reapers haven't attacked and jeopard was
presumed dead so they all had to move on
in Mass Effect 3 that's not the case the
reapers are approaching so there's no
time to take down rival gangs on Omega
or overthrow the shadow broker but still
even with the lack of attention put on
the companions most of them are likable
and interesting characters and being
able to spend some down time with them
on the Citadel was a nice change of pace
continuing where we left off we just
finished handling the war between the
quarians and the Geth since that's over
though we need a new objective
thankfully the asari counselor has
something she wants to tell us that
could help the war effort apparently on
thessia the asari Homeworld there is an
artifact that is integral to winning the
war we just need to find our way to get
there since the SEO is being overrun by
Reaper forces just like in the previous
games picking specific companions during
missions can reward different dialogue
and javik is essential for this Mission
Mass Effect 3 though sadly doesn't have
a lot of these unique interactions since
most emissions will give you a required
companion like Tali being present during
most of Act 2 but there is at least this
interaction the reason javik is so
important is because we learned that the
protheans were the gods of the asari
asari culture used to worship a God name
a theme who helped grow the asari people
she taught them things like how to grow
crops how to use biotics and even
protected them from danger with her
shield and sword javicle chime in during
this dialogue and say that the protheans
did not want her pupil to starve and
also how a meteor shower was going to
rain down on thessia so they deflected
it this would also explain how javik
knows biotics since his people either
created it or learned it from another
race and then passed it down to the
asari furthermore inside the Statue of a
theme was a prothean beacon this is the
artifact that the asari counselor was
talking about as inside it is a prothean
VI javik obviously expresses his
distaste for the asari using his
people's technology for their own gain
without telling anyone about it but
Liara is just as surprised as we are
since she didn't even know this Beacon
existed this admittedly has Liara all
shaken up since her entire religion was
a lie now to be fair most is sorry
including Liara don't worship a theme
but it was a core part of their species
at one point in time so it is still a
shocking Revelation according to the vi
it says that these cycles of Destruction
are intentional and are almost machine
like there seems to be the same peaks of
evolution and the same values of
disillusion in every cycle there are
even similar conflicts in each cycle
like how Cerberus is fighting against
everyone in order to control the Reapers
the vi believes that the Reapers aren't
responsible for the pattern but are
responsible for carrying it out meaning
something is ordering the Reapers around
and telling them to harvest the vi sadly
doesn't know who the leader is but all
it knows is that it wants Galactic
annihilation we asked the vi to join us
and did agrees but it ends up hiding as
an indoctrinated presence is nearby that
presence is none other than kai Lang and
The elusive man
subtlety has never been in Mass Effect
3's Playbook The elusive man that does
his usual stick of telling Shepherd that
his plan is better and that controlling
the Reapers is the only way after
knowing his plan The elusive man orders
Kai Lang to kill the group and retrieve
the vi as we talked about earlier this
is the encounter where Kai Lang is
guaranteed to win and you can see the
massive disconnect from gameplay to cut
scene since he goes down super quickly
in game and then magically gathers
enough strength to overpower the group
with ease I do like the fact that he
brought a high into the fight since you
really need to throw everything you got
it Shepherd in order to kill him I just
wish it could have been a part of the
fight rather than an obstacle that
forces us to take cover while Kai Lane
recharges Kai Lang then destroys the
church and steals the vi leaving the
crew to die to make matters worse thusia
is being overrun by the Reapers so not
only is the asari Homeworld being
destroyed but the team didn't even
complete their objective this is the
first major failure the team has
experienced all game and it hits
everyone pretty hard including Liara she
not only lost her Homeworld but also
learned the truth about her people's
upbringing it really brings them all the
crew down to rock a bottom and while I'm
all for this reaction as it's normal to
be disappointed after a defeat such as
this it's kind of ruined when you
remember that it's Kai Lang who cost us
the victory this Mission didn't make me
hate Kai Lang I've already hated him the
moment he came on screen it makes me
hate the fact that we lost an unwinnable
fight against a ninja with plot armor
with the mission done though we're
pretty much finished vessio was our
final lead and we can't get Kai Lang
since we don't know where the elusive
men and his headquarters are stationed
however according to specialist trainer
Kai Lang's signal went off when they
reached the Lara system according to
Edie there is a place called sanctuary
in that system and she believes that
this is where they're located specialist
trainer by the way replaces Kelly
Chambers position in Mass Effect 2 so
she'll tell us when some of the crew
want to speak with us and when we have
new messages but she is way more
competent than Kelly since she actually
goes out of her way to find distressed
beacons that others have sent out like
the one at Grissom Academy which we'll
cover in a bit so her noticing this
detail doesn't really seem too
outlandish it also may seem a bit
far-fetched that this is the one place
they could be when we're talking about a
whole solar system here but from reading
the description of the planets and the
system it seems like Horizon the planet
where Sanctuary is on is the only place
that can actually sustain any life as
the other planets either have no oxygen
levels or gas planets a second ago I
just mentioned horizon horizon of course
being the same place who went in Mass
Effect 2 and found the vermeyer Survivor
speaking of them you can bring them
along for this Mission but they sadly
have no dialogue it does partially make
sense since Sanctuary seems to be built
after the collector attack since the
facility is supposed to be a safe haven
for those Escaping The Reaper War but I
still think some dialogue from them
could have gone a long way after going
through the facility we discovered that
Sanctuary was well anything but
Sanctuary is actually a covert base made
by Cerberus which used the people here
as test subjects that they could
experiment with husk creation by
creating their own husks servers can
further understand the indoctrination
process which is critical to their goal
of controlling the Reapers it seems like
the Reapers found out about this as well
as we actually arrive late to the party
as Cerberus and the Reapers have already
begun fighting so it seems like the
elusive man is fighting off the
indoctrination and is able to have some
cognitive awareness similar to sarin on
vermeier in the facility though are a
few Terminals and by watching the videos
recorded on them we can discover that
Miranda her father her sister and Kai
Ling are all here
what a family reunion Miranda's father
Henry runs the facility and he also
captured Miranda's sister which is why
they're both here Kai Lang is just here
to get the data from the facility before
it's overrun and maybe deal with Miranda
if she gets in his way once we catch up
with the family we have some options on
how to deal with this you can talk Henry
Dunn which gives Miranda enough time to
throw him out the window or you can
shoot orianna in the leg opening her
father up for another shot I'm kind of
surprised that she was fine with this
since she never screams in pain or
anything maybe that just comes to being
genetically perfect as for Kai Lang well
apparently he ran off again but somehow
Miranda put a tracking device on him
kind of surprised no one noticed that
but okay I guess without Miranda's help
though the team gets enough info to find
the base anyway thanks to some leftover
logs so it really doesn't matter with
this mission complete though we're now
finished with act 2. overall I think the
first half of Act 2 was a lot better as
there was an actual story to the ACT but
the SEO was pretty good minus the fight
with Kai Lang and this mission on
Sanctuary was all right it's not
insanely impressive but not bad enough
to actually call it a waste after this
though we'll talk with the team and find
the location of the Cerberus
headquarters but starting this Mission
brings us past the point of no return so
before we do that let's talk about some
side content then finish up with some
DLC
so Mass Effect 3 has four kinds of side
content which I call Companion missions
and seven missions Citadel missions and
Citadel things
I'll get to that in a moment these are
what I call these missions because Mass
Effect 3 refused to do so itself in Mass
Effect 1 and 2 your quests were
organized by missions and assignments
missions were main missions like
recruiting a companion or going to a
specific place during the main quest
assignments were side missions such as
finding Brandy for Dr shockwas or
settling a dispute between Aquarian and
a Volus Mass Effect 3 just completely
removes this tab in the journal so every
Quest is on the same page which starts
to create quite a mess this wouldn't be
half as bad if the Citadel missions were
not the main cause of this issue the
Citadel missions are found by walking
near people and listening in on
conversations just passing by the quest
Giver will likely give you a mission
even if you didn't want it all your
tasks with doing is going to the
location that's in the journal and
finding the object by scanning the
planet that is if you can find the
planet to begin with the Citadel
missions are labeled with a name before
the title if the name says Citadel on it
nine times out of ten they're found
during the N7 missions which is
something I only found out after
finishing the game the others are a
complete toss-up one of them started
with Hades Nexus a class on the Galaxy
map which means somewhere in this
cluster is the planet we need it's
tedious but it Narrows the search down a
ton however it can also be the opposite
another one started with irune that's
the name of the planet so now we know
what planet we're looking for but don't
know the system or cluster do you know
how many of those exist in this game
there is no way I'm going through every
system just to find a book that may or
may not actually help me even if you
find the planet you'll have to skin it
to actually inspect it which depending
on the location could attract a Reapers
a new addition to Mass Effect 3 is
reapers on the Galaxy map if you press
the scan button you can scan the solar
system if a red circle appears that
means something is there but scanning
attracts the Reapers and after enough
time they'll attack you you can't fight
back though you have to escape or you
die if you do die then you're just sent
back to right before they enter the
solar system meaning they'll still
attack you even if you escape they'll
still come back even if you return the
only way to bring them back to their
original state is by completing one main
mission something the game also doesn't
tell you this can make it extremely
difficult to find the item you're
looking for such as the one in the Hades
Nexus since I actually have to scan the
planets the one on a rune isn't too bad
since I can just hover over them to see
its name but regardless each one is
tedious it just depends on what kind of
tedium we're talking about Also
regarding the scanning this is all you
can do on the Galaxy map Mass Effect 3
has no Planetary Exploration like the
first game or resource Gathering like
the second so 90 of the time it's not
even worth inspecting a planet so all in
all the Citadel missions are quite
annoying to do but we haven't even
talked about the worst part which is
that each Quest can either be time
sensitive or progress sensitive time
sensitive means we can only do a set
number of missions before it fails the
bomb on tuchanko was time sensitive if
we did three missions after receiving
this Quest then it fails because we
didn't do the mission in time progress
sensitive means it fails after a
specific main quest for example One
mission called Citadel bar Lavon has to
be completed before tachanka however
this goes both ways this exact Mission
also has a prerequisite which means it
cannot be completed until after Cirque
but we get this after palaven so in
order of events we do the mission on
palaven's moon where we meet Garris go
to the Citadel and possibly find this
Mission but then have to wait until
after sirkesh which is where we rescue
Eve because for some odd reason it's
unavailable but then we also have to
make sure it's done before tachanka
which is the next domain Mission so we
only have one time frame to actually do
this Quest it is the most confusing
Quest system I have ever seen in a game
before in a vacuum I think the progress
sensitive concept is a good idea but
with all these prerequisites and lack of
information regarding when the mission
can even be started or where it even is
it just makes these unbearable besides
the Citadel missions we have Citadel
things and I cannot figure out who these
are for sometimes on the Citadel you'll
overhear a discussion between two people
and can decide who to side with all
these do is reward some reputation and
maybe some more assets depending on the
discussion it's just such a strange
activity to me though because it's just
Shepard going up to everyone on the
Citadel butting into their conversation
to offer some advice and then leaving
without any elaboration I can see how
this could be cool to some people as
your decisions are impacting people's
lives I just cannot get over how awkward
these are however there are a few
discussions I actually enjoyed sometimes
when visiting the Citadel you'll
overheard some people talking but
they're neither Quest givers nor are
they having an argument these
conversations are our main reason why I
enjoyed walking through the Citadel
probably the best one is this asari
Huntress who is currently suffering from
PTSD when you first approach them they
say a couple lines of dialogue and then
stop talking when you leave the hospital
and come back though they continue the
next set of lines you can keep doing
this over and over again until the
conversation is finished this is also
how I discovered information about Liara
since eavesdropping on their
conversation is the only way to hear
more about them the main reason I like
this specific conversation is because
it's related to Joker according to the
asari hunter she was on a planet called
tip tree to make a long story short the
huntress ended up meeting a girl named
Hillary and had to survive against a
Reaper attack Hillary seems to be a
teenager judging by what she says so the
huntress was doing most of the Dirty
Work the story ends on a sad note though
as Hillary broke her leg and wouldn't
stop crying so the hunters had to decide
between killing Hillary or revealing
their position she chose to kill her
which was the main source of her PTSD as
any time she sees a human now she freaks
out this was confirmed by one of the
writers to be Joker's sister since Joker
will talk about his family living on tip
tree not all of them are as good as this
one but I did enjoy the concept of these
conversations and she'll be returning to
the Citadel a lot so it creates this
sort of natural flow of dialogue or you
could just change floors and come back
if you're impatient like me as for the
N7 missions they're similar to most of
the basic side quests in Mass Effect 2
land on a planet do a thing and get out
in about 5 minutes I have the same
opinion of these quests as I did in Mass
Effect 2. they're okay for the most part
but the real highlight being the sky
boxes and structures outside the
playable area one thing Mass Effect 3
does improve though is the mission
structure since the majority of these
missions involve Cerberus so you could
say that doing these is worth it since
we're disrupting cerberus's operations
whereas in Mass Effect 2 we were just
doing different things for different
people the last and easily the best of
the bunch in regards to Mass Effect 3
side content is the companion missions
there are quite a few missions in Mass
Effect 3 that will have us running into
our old crew from Mass Effect 2. the
only problem with them is that similar
to the mission with grunt when the
companions aren't there the missions
aren't that great take this mission
where we have to find these ex-serberus
scientists who are under attack from
Cerberus forces this mission is quite
out of place and nothing of importance
really happens on this Mission but
that's because most of it rides on Jacob
being alive so the player can catch up
with their old crewmate we already
talked about grunt but besides him we
can also catch up with Kasumi zaeed
Jacob Samara and Jack there's also a
short interaction with Miranda on the
Citadel but that's not really a part of
a mission the two of you just catch up
and talk about what Miranda is up to
which is why we find her at Sanctuary a
bit later probably the best of the bunch
are Jack and Samara Jack after leaving
the Normandy attended Grissom Academy
and became a teacher there since the
academy is dedicated to training biotic
students she of course is a complete
hard ass when it comes to teaching but
you can tell she really likes her
students and willingly step into danger
to make sure they're okay this Mission
also gives us some insight into biotics
as some of the students ask for a break
since they haven't eaten and need to
recharge the way they talk about this
though implies that their biotic Powers
consume the nutrients they eat so the
more they eat the more they can burn I
don't recall this ever being mentioned
before at least not in dialogue so that
wasn't interesting detail to learn about
during the mission after we rescue her
student she goes with them to fight the
Reapers as their needed thanks to their
biotic potential but you can also visit
her on the Citadel for a brief chat if
you want to I really do like this change
for Jax and she grew up in a biotic camp
and was basically tortured but now she's
on the other side of the table and given
her past refuses to let that happen to
her students this of course comes with
some side effects as she has to follow
regulations and can't swear in front of
the students so even though Jack has
changed a bit she still has the same
personality that we all know and love
samara's Mission comes after the coup on
the Citadel we get a mission from the
asari counselor about an ardad yakshi
Monastery being attacked since a group
of asari Commandos went to check the
place out but never reported in this is
where we learn about the Banshee enemies
and discovered that they were ardad
yakshi that had been altered thanks to
the Reapers as you would expect we find
Samara here we can actually meet her
other two daughters if you remember from
one of our conversations with Samara we
know that she swore the justikar oath
and left her daughters at the monastery
she hasn't seen them since that day
since she was dedicated to stopping
[ __ ] so this is the first time the
family has seen each other in over 400
years sadly it's not all sunshine or
rainbows though since one of the
daughters started turning momentarily
before being knocked out that daughter
also opts to stay behind and lure the
Banshees into the monasteries that she
can blow them all up this bomb was
originally placed here by the asari
Commandos but seeing as they likely died
the Detonator is still functional this
blows up some of the monastery and kills
samara's second daughter after the Samar
goes into the speech about her
daughter's death reminding her about
what's truly important in life and why
she became a Jessica and it was a really
great speech until she pulls out a gun
and almost kills herself according to
the justica code in order yakshi cannot
live outside the monastery and since the
monastery is blown up she has to kill
her daughter but Samara won't kill her
last daughter so she opts to take her
own life instead I get why she's doing
this she's showing that the love for her
daughter outweighs her code unless she
needs to end her life but I don't think
we needed to go that far I've been
pretty tolerant of samara's code for the
most part even though a lot of the rules
make very little sense like how she
would have been forced to kill the
officers at the station in Mass Effect 2
if they didn't release her but this one
was just way too much for me plus the
monastery isn't even gone it's just a
bit wrecked and her daughter decides to
stay in the war-torn building anyway so
her taking a bullet would have been
unnecessary after this though we can
talk to Samara again but she mentions
how she's leaving and just wanted to say
a proper goodbye these missions are
definitely the best in the group thanks
to the actual stories being quite
interesting even without the companions
inclusion saving biotic students
especially human ones and also checking
in on a monastery for the asari
counselor are decent enough reasons to
get the player to check them out so even
without Jack and Samara they were
passable missions the same cannot be
said for the others though zaid's
mission is centered around a Volus
Ambassador who may be working with
Cerberus after investigating his office
we can find the room he's in along with
Zaid who will be alive if loyal or dead
if not that's pretty much it Zaid also
doesn't offer much in terms of dialogue
other than him talking about how he's
trying to hunt down Cerberus agents and
that if Shepard needs he can get some
buddies he can round up for the war but
like I said that's pretty much it
kasumis is centered around an
indoctrinated Hannah who's trying to
sabotage his own homeworld's defense
systems he then work with a Solari
inspector to track and take him down the
only reason Kasumi is even relevant to
this mission is because the gray box
from kg had this information on it it
doesn't matter if she kept the box or
not or even if she's alive since the
information gets found one way or
another I think the biggest crime this
Mission commits is downplaying the
specters again all I have ever wanted is
just one Mission with an established
Specter and everyone we've met has
either died betrayed us
betrayed us or actually did their job
but had a mission that was quite boring
working with televasir during the lair
of the Shadow broker was still a major
highlight of that DLC I just wish she
didn't betray us technically since Kaden
and Ashley become specters they fulfill
my goal but it doesn't feel the same
since they just became a specter and we
knew them prior to getting that title
with televasir it was like okay we're
both specters we know how to get things
done so let's just cut the [ __ ] and
get straight to business it felt like
two professionals were teaming up
together and that was an exciting part
of the DLC since spector's working with
one another is quite rare I just wish we
could get a proper Mission with that
same feeling talking with Kasumi doesn't
amount to much either as she really
doesn't add anything to the conversation
we can offer her a spot on the Normandy
again but she declines and for Jacob
well we already went over his mission
ex-serber scientists are trying to leave
without getting shot by Cerberus
soldiers and we come in to help the only
important detail that is worth talking
about is that Jacob is dating this Dr
Brynn and is expecting a child this is
cool but this is also around the time I
discovered how shafted femshep gets in
this game when it comes to Rome
especially if she's straight male
Shepard has seven different options for
straight romances Jack Miranda Liara
Tali Ashley Kelly Chambers and Diana
allers femshep only has four Kaden Thane
Garris and Jacob Caden is knocked out
for half the game Thane dies halfway
through the game and Jacob straight up
cheats on you which is the first time
I've ever seen a companion in any RPG do
that the only full game option is Garris
this personally doesn't affect me but I
did go down a rabbit hole of information
about romanceable characters one day and
wanted to share my strange findings with
you all as you can see though these
missions aren't as good as the first two
and it's mostly because of how dependent
the mission is on the companions being
alive or in some cases it's still pretty
poor when they are alive the one thing
these missions do bring to the table
though is the opportunity to catch up
with some of the old cast and this I can
see being quite an issue for some people
those who are a bit more nitpicky than
me may claim that Shepard finding all
these people all the time is unrealistic
which is a totally fair point but on the
other side of the coin people might be
mad these characters never show up
despite having a prominent role in the
previous game their inclusion ends up
creating a double-edged sword damned if
you do damned if you don't I think if I
had to pick one though I'd probably go
with how the game is structured now
since I'd rather have the worst problem
being how unrealistic it is that they'd
meet Shepard rather than it just being
how they don't show up at all and thus
are a waste of time as a complete
package Mass Effect 3's Quest like its
story is one of high highs and low lows
Mass Effect 3 has both sides of the
spectrum when the quests are good
they're really good and when they're
disappointing they're really
disappointing I think out of the trilogy
Mass Effect 1 still has the best
Planetary Exploration which is kind of
unfair since it's the only game to have
it but in terms of quest design I think
I still have to give it to Mass Effect
1. it wasn't fun going through the same
hallways and corridors just to read some
text about an event we never saw happen
but I think it was much better than Mass
Effect 2's attempt at it which is very
similar to three with the exception of
some of the companion missions that of
course being just a small Arena to walk
around in with a good enough Skybox to
look at but not enough room to actually
explore
as for the DLC we have five to talk
about but we'll be saving one for later
since it focuses on the ending of the
game as for the other four the first one
we have is called From the Ashes we
received information that there is a
protein artifact on Eden Prime if we go
back to Eden Prime the same place we
visited all the way back in Mass Effect
1 we'll uncover a pod with an alien in
it this alien's name is javik and he's a
prothean the only one of his kind
if you're wondering why I just repeated
what I said earlier than you're catching
on because javic is DLC but you likely
wouldn't have known that given how
important he is to the story The last
time we talked about DLC characters was
when we met with Kasumi and Zaid but
both were very clearly built around the
game rather than in it both had
recruitment missions immediately upon
starting the game gave us their loyalty
Mission soon after recruiting them and
are the only two people in the game that
can't be talked to normally as we have
to interact with our stuff in order to
talk to them they felt like DLC because
they were javik is nothing like that
despite not being a part of the base
game this is because javik was made
during the certification process even
taking a brief look at the development
history of the game will show you that
this game was rushed both Mass Effect 2
and 3 seemed to start development before
the previous games were released the
problem though is that Mass Effect 2 had
about 3 years of time while massive act
3 had two years of time furthermore Mass
Effect 3 had double The Voice lines of
multiplayer mode and quite a few new
additions on top of that that's not a
whole lot of time as such the team
needed to make some drastic Cuts javik
was sadly one of them the thing is
though is that he made it on time he was
day one DLC this of course is because of
that certification process Mass Effect 3
like any game had to be certified but if
they spent time on javik they would have
had to extend the date of certification
and thus the date of the game so they
shipped the game without him in it and
during the three months it took to be
certified they reconstructed javik's
recruitment Mission along with anything
else he was supposed to be a part of so
that it didn't feel out of place for
those who didn't buy the DLC I
absolutely despise the idea of day one
DLC especially if it's story content
like this but reading the development
makes me less angry about the whole
ordeal I still don't like it but most of
my disgust is now directed towards EA
who I can only assume are the people
that wanted Mass Effect 3 to have such a
short development time in the first
place thankfully the legendary Edition
comes with all the DLC so those just
starting the series for the first time
will never run into this problem but
that doesn't excuse the fact that at one
point it was a problem quite a few
people probably played Mass Effect 3
without javik since he was additional
content and didn't think it was going to
be anything important since Kasumi and
Zaid weren't as important to match
effect 2. this makes the SEO a
completely different Mission as javik no
longer interjects mid-conversation to
talk about the prothean history in our
Renegade playthrough we never picked
javik up so he wasn't present for this
year and while the yara's dialogue is
still the same javik is in there to
correct her so it's never stated that
the protheans were their gods you could
possibly come to this conclusion anyway
since the beacon is still inside the
asari Statue but that wouldn't work
either because there was one on Eden
Prime so it wouldn't make any sense that
the protheans are the gods of the asari
it would just further confirm that the
asari government tried to hide and
harness the prothium power furthermore
anything we learned from javik has
immediately tossed out the window since
he wouldn't be present however the game
does try to remedy this by bringing it
up anyway like when javik told us that
there were indoctrinated protheans that
were trying to control the Reapers just
like what Cerberus is doing now which is
something the vi anthesia tells us
anyway regardless if javik is present
they also made javik a soldier instead
of some other protheon so that he
wouldn't have the knowledge on The
Crucible or Catalyst something the main
quest will eventually explain to us as
well so to be fair in terms of quest
relevant details we're not missing out
on much but we are missing out on a
plethora of information from the species
history to their technology which even
though isn't main quest relevant is
arguably just as important when talking
about the story of Mass Effect all this
goes back to our earlier discussion
about the game's story saying to
chanka's Mission suck because of Riven
Paddock is kind of like saying thessia
sucked because javik wasn't present
while the story can have multiple paths
it's very obvious that one is the better
choice and has the more appealing story
it's just a real shame that javik wasn't
a part of the base game thankfully the
next three DLC were not Day One content
so let's start with the first part of
the Mass Effect 3 post launch content
that being the DLC Omega
Omega Stars Arya talok the same woman in
Mass Effect 2 who claimed that she was
Omega which is ironic since she isn't
Omega anymore thanks to Cerberus driving
her out she wants Shepard to help get
her throne back this is an odd request
given we have a war going on but we
would be putting a stop to cerberus's
operations again and seeing as they were
testing on the people of sanctuary it
makes sense why they're doing the same
to the people of Omega plus Arya says
she has a large shipment of element zero
with her name on it and given how rare
it is to find element zero if Mass
Effect 2 is anything to go off of it's
probably smart if we help her Arya to
Loke right away makes it pretty clear
that her attitude matches her decision
making Reckless her master plan is to
force her way past omega's defenses
using Brute Force despite the fact that
General petrovsky the current head of
Omega says that they've upgraded the
place's defenses I'm really starting to
see how she lost control of this place
as with most things involving Shepard
sheer luck and determination when in the
end and they somehow make it side we
didn't have to get through lots of
cerber soldiers to get to our actual
objective though the biggest change
Omega makes to the gameplay is giving us
Arya as a temporary companion she isn't
drastically different than Liara or
Samara but having Arya tag along was
pretty cool once we make some footing
and dig deep enough into Omega Arya and
Company set up a base of operations from
here we can continue the main quest or
do some side missions but the side
missions aren't exactly side missions
they are all missions that can be
completed in the main quest for example
This girl wants us to hack some devices
for her these devices are only found
during the main quest locations because
Omega is a very linear DLC this isn't a
problem really just don't expect to
explore Omega like we used to back in
Mass Effect 2. one thing I am glad was
kept in this DLC was the detail of Omega
it was always run down and grimy it was
kind of like a poor man Citadel and the
DLC continues to push that idea while
Aryan Shepard push deeper into Omega the
two come across some strange markings
these are the insignias of a group
called Talons their leader though is
nyrene a female Tyrion and arya's former
lover nyrene and Arya couldn't be more
different if they tried nyrene is all
about saving people whereas arya's more
of an ends justify the means kind of
person you might ask how they even
managed to get together and while their
former lovers so include and last long
but opposites do attract after all
Narine is used in the story as a paragon
alternative to arya's Renegade attitude
I wish this would have went somewhere
but sadly this isn't the case because
nyrene doesn't offer much to the game
there are some small and interesting
details we learned from her but that's
about it from our conversations with her
we learned that one Cerberus took over
Omega they started experimenting on the
citizens and created new creatures
called adjectives she has a fear of
these creatures thanks to her seeing a
lot of her friends and allies be turned
into them nyrene would then work and
then eventually lead the talons in
taking back Omega but now that arya's
here this creates a bit of tension as
Arya wants the throne back and isn't
willing to let the talons have it
besides that we learned that she was a
part of the Taurean military but was
kicked out when she started manifesting
biotic abilities this seems to imply
that the Taurean military only wants raw
strength and not magical powers other
than that though that's about it Nadine
is cool I guess I did find myself drawn
to her a bit but only because she's the
first female turian We Ever Meet but
nothing really comes from it as I said
before when talking about Eve I just
wish that a lot of the races had more
women present so we could learn more
about the racist history and culture but
nyrene really doesn't give us any info
on the topic this isn't really nyrene's
fault though because in the context of a
DLC when would talking about her racist
history be appropriate she's just the
one that gets the criticism because
she's the only female terrium we talk to
after this Shepherd will then meet with
nyrene and Arya to discuss how they'll
make it to the afterlife so Arya can get
her throne back this mission is where we
learn about the adjectives Origins and
why nyrene is so scared of them the only
other thing of note to mention is the
final decision of this quest which is
deciding whether or not to remove power
from the reactor because Narine and Arya
are trapped inside a force field and are
being swarmed by mechs turning off the
reactor would destroy the force field
but also remove any life support systems
in a few dozen Wards on Omega meaning do
we take the quick option and sacrifice
the many to save the few or do we try to
find an alternative waiting is the only
decent option since there is no
repercussions for doing so no one dies
if we wait despite the fact that the
game seemed to imply nerine would likely
die once the group makes it to the
afterlife nyrene runs ahead and decides
to face the edgerton's head on it's
quite a nice change of character since
she realizes her fear of these creatures
shouldn't outweigh her goal of saving
people it's just a bit jarring that she
sacrifices herself and dies
I don't know I just feel like that
wasn't really necessary it makes sense
that she would do this seeing as she was
about to be overrun I'm just confused
why the writers opted to create a
situation that would force nyrene to
sacrifice herself I didn't really feel
anything during that scene I was more
shocked actually because I originally
thought that she put the shield up to
protect herself from the blast not to
hold the blast inside the shield it does
finally kick Arya into action and seeing
an asari biotic go crazy is always a
sight to behold it's just weird that she
needed that to get going you know not
the fact that some Cerberus jackass just
stole her City due to her hot-headed
approach Arya gets captured but Shepard
will end up breaking her out and the two
confront petrovsky one thing I must
compliment Omega 4 is its final decision
it's not major but there is still a few
things we did in the DLC that impacted
Arya depending on some of our choices
Arya will either spare him kill him or
leave it up to Shepherd to decide now
these aren't major decisions but I think
that's what I like about them the most
obvious one is deciding whether or not
to turn off the reactor turning off its
power was arya's idea which solidifies
her Reckless Behavior but keeping it up
allows him of Shepherd and Irene mean to
rub off on her which makes her hesitant
to kill petrovsky the other decisions
though are random dialogue like sticking
up for an Irene or telling Arya to not
do something dangerous their minor
choices with major impacts now
admittedly despite it feeling impactful
sparing or killing petrovsky really
doesn't do much other than just giving
the player War assets plus Arya gets
Omega anyway it just depends on whether
or not she'll rule Omega like she used
to with her destructive attitude as for
petrovsky he's at the very least an
interesting antagonist because according
to nyrene he offered amnesty to Talon
members who decided not to fight him and
he kept his word she'll then eventually
go on to say that while he may be allied
with Cerberus his mindset and ideals
don't really match that of The elusive
man with all those details laid out I
was wondering if Omega was going to have
some sort of grand Choice like leaving
Omega to petrovsky with forcing him to
cut ties with Cerberus or maybe even
letting nyrene run things but there was
never a choice like that you may be
surprised how fast we finished talking
about Omega and that's because most of
its run time is spent killing things
which is fine it's just that there's not
much to talk about the real selling
point of the DLC is being able to team
up with Arya and getting a chance to
revisit Omega and if we're to just focus
on those things alone I say the DLC is
quite good because it was fun to fight
alongside Arya and see Omega again but I
do wish we got to spend a bit more time
here since we would have been able to
see the outcome of our choices and get
to hang out with Arya a bit overall
though Omega is a quick bite-sized
Adventure on one of mass effect's
well-known locations and it was a
serviceable distraction from the main
content probably the most appropriate
DLC to talk about next would be
Leviathan but instead I want to talk
about The Citadel first Citadel was the
final DLC for Mass Effect 3 and thus the
final DLC for the trilogy which is by
the story for this DLC is so strange
basically the plot is that Shepard is
being hunted by another group of people
people this time called Cat6 and leading
their group is a clone of Shepherd who
also takes the Normandy so a real
Shepherd will have to get the Normandy
back by killing clone Shepard like I
said the plot is extremely weird but
that's intentional since it was supposed
to be a way to send off the series so
the DLC is very comedic and
light-hearted while this isn't a
terrible idea it can come off the wrong
way by accident since this is disguised
as any other mission in the game so
going from the main quest to this would
be quite the tonal Whiplash that's why I
recommend you either do this before
starting the final mission or even doing
this after you beat the game since it's
a great way to finish your Trilogy Long
play through the DLC starts with an
email from Anderson he wants Shepard to
have his apartment which is quite a
selfless decision considering the fact
he's still on the front lines of a war
after getting a feel for the place we
then meet Joker for some dinner the
reason we're even doing this during the
war is because the Normandy is in need
of a retrofit so while the Normandy is
being repaired in service the crew
decides to take a load off in the
meantime the two come to find out though
that something is wrong because Joker
thought Shepard invited him and Shepard
that joker invited him shortly after
this an alliance officer clumsily walks
in in and introduces herself Maya Brooks
here claims that a Merc group is after
Shepard thankfully we don't have to do
the hard work as that was already done
for us thanks to this exact group
raiding the building it's right about
here when it comes pretty obvious that
the DLC has a heavy focus on comedy
jokes and comedy can be quite hard to
discuss because everyone finds different
things funny but there were times when I
thought the game just went too far
comedy is nice in context and when it
sparse and while the Citadel has some
hilarious lines most just felt too
forced for me
I'm going after her find the crew got it
hey
[Music]
you used me as bait go
do you use me as bait
did you see that savior of the Citadel
use the turtle bones guy in the bank
I think the idea of repeating a joke
until it wears out ruins the initial
punchline and the game does this again
because during this firefight Shepherd
falls through the sushi restaurant and
the crew Reams him over this to the
point where I was just so sick of
hearing about it
I'm relieved to see you're in one piece
a shame about the sushi place though it
was a favorite
to me inside but I think to myself
someday when I've proven my worth to the
Galaxy I'll go there for dinner
and then you broke their floor I'm fine
by the way
restaurant attack has made the news
he seem to have been restricted to
fish
commander in my cycle when we fled
combat by falling through tanks
containing aquatic animals we usually
oh right we never did
you are a trailblazer
oh they shut down my favorite sushi
place
that's a shame
[Music]
Shepherd you didn't
I did
fell right through the fish tank how did
you manage that
it's exploded
I get it it was funny and maybe a little
embarrassing but do we need to mention
it five different times that's not to
say all of it was bad though because
Citadel was a great DLC and it got quite
a few laughs out of me especially
towards the end it's just that some of
these jokes ended up ruining their own
punch lines most of the early missions
also allow us to stealth our way through
them but I couldn't for the life of me
figure this out similar to kasumi's
loyalty Mission the stealth in this DLC
is Clumsy we did at least get a
suppressed pistol which is a start but
the stealth sections aren't really
stealth sections enemies are alerted
instantly and will alert others upon
being shot you have to download quick
enough to prevent this from happening
but given that it takes about three
shots to the head to down them you
likely won't have the time I'm also
fairly certain there are no melee
takedowns like other stealth games have
but even if they did exist I couldn't
find a proper time to use them since I'd
be spotted right away anyway it's a bit
better than kasumi's Mission but only
because we actually get a suppressed
weapon but her Mission though felt like
a stealth Mission even with the loud
pistol because we were trying to not get
caught in this Mission it doesn't matter
if you're caught because enemies will
die quick and the pistol's damage is
busted this actually became my go-to
weapon for the final mission because of
how fast this thing chews through armor
regardless it wasn't a bad attempt but
it's hard to expect a stealth section to
work in a series that's never been built
around stealth after this though Shepard
will run into some of the old crew and
then we'll meet with him to discuss what
to do next liaro ran some tests on the
pistol since it's the weapon one of the
guards is using and her Rabbit Hole of
information led her to a man named
Elijah Khan he's been suspected of
smuggling weapons into the Citadel so
we'll need to find him to see if we can
get more information on these Cat6 mercs
this means we'll have to infiltrate the
casino undetected this is also a revamp
of kasumi's loyalty Mission and in this
case is much better you're allowed to
mingle and talk with partygoers as well
as hack a new security cameras so that
they're disabled you can also bring a
crew member along which can lead to some
great dialogue I kept replaying some of
these missions to hear the dialogue
since that's where the bulk of the
comedy comes from seeing all the
crewmates in their different outfits and
their reactions to wearing such outfits
was great to run through especially when
it came to guys like Rex javik and
Garris who aren't too keen on formal
attire
I look ridiculous after spending longer
than I want to admit losing my money on
Varan racing Brooke says that the door
is ready to be open and once we arrive
we can see that Elijah is dead once
again the team reconvenes it discovers
that this mysterious person they found
at the casino is using Shepard Specter
status to access the Citadel archives so
the team gears up and makes it to the
archives which is why we discover that
the bad guy is a clone as for how that's
even possible apparently service created
another Shepherd using the current
Shepherd's DNA so that he could be used
as spare parts if Shepard needed another
arm leg or lung then the Clone would be
the donor but clearly Cerberus didn't
need him but never thought to throw him
away which is why he eventually woke up
according to him while Shepard was stuck
on Earth in between games he was just
getting out of his coma and learning how
to be human also if you're wondering why
this random Alliance officer is so
important well that's because Brooks
here is working with the cologne and
ends up betraying us later in this
Mission I think it's quite obvious
something was up with her but I'm
honestly glad she's not a part of the
team anymore since her dialogue is
insufferable to listen to apparently
Brooks was also the one who put together
the dossier for our team in Mass Effect
2 which is kind of an interesting detail
But ultimately not too important I think
the DLC tried to make Brooks important
and not just some random person which is
cool I guess but I kind of like the idea
that it was The elusive man who actually
put it together and not one of his old
Associates thankfully though this
mission is where the comedy really
starts to take off
refresh my memory
didn't we used
to win these things but
he said I should go
do I sound like that
as long as I've known you yeah
crazy thought but maybe we should be
worrying about this impregnable Vault
we've been sealed inside forever
how come nobody told me this before
I'm open to feedback here
well I thought all humans said it like
some weird Earth custom or something
probably not a lot of air in here either
an hour if we're lucky maybe it's I
should go
I should go
I should go
Shepherd please why aren't you more
worried about this once glyph comes by
and unlocks the vaulter seal then the
team races to the Normandy to take it
back the crew can't get in until trainer
comes by and then decides to use her
toothbrush as a makeshift lockpick this
is completely absurd but may have been
the greatest joke in this DLC since the
first thing trainer talks about when you
first get on the Normandy is her
toothbrush and I couldn't help but
appreciate the Callback Shepard will
then have to face Brooks and the Clone
who has an identical moveset to you
which means the two of us ended up
spamming biotics until one of us went
down both of the Shepherds during their
Scuttle also fall off the ship until the
crew comes by to help I like the
dichotomy here between both Shepherds
because it shows that you can't just be
someone by copying their looks this
clone could never be Shepherd because he
was never able to inspire such a large
group of people that's why our crew
helps us in the end and Brooks leaves
the Clone to die speaking of dying
though Brooks gets quite a satisfying
death assuming you let her Escape which
is something I've always done this final
scene ends up being the end of the
mission but not the DLC as the main
reward for beating it is a giant party
but overall I think the missions were
all right how ever once I analyze this
from a different perspective I started
appreciating this a lot more when
looking up some videos on some of the
unique dialogue for the DLC I saw a
comment that said that this Mission
should have been renamed to Shepard's
loyalty Mission and after hearing that I
couldn't look at this DLC any other way
we as Shepard spent so long helping
others with their problems and now it's
time they paid us back you could claim
that fighting the Reapers and collectors
is more than enough and that's true but
the difference is that the Loyalty
missions were all personal to them it
never had to do with a galaxy-wide
threat that was just something we all
came together to fight but finding the
gray box for Kasumi hunting month for
Samara and taking grunt through puberty
and all the other missions were all
personal problems that specific crew
member had Shepard's personal problem
was a group of mercenaries trying to
kill him and take his identity this
loyalty Mission idea really clicked for
me when in one of the scenes Shepard
needed backup but before he could even
finish his sentence everyone was
providing support not only did they have
his back but they knew what to do and
when because they've been with him for
so long these missions also seem to want
to portray this idea because all the
crew shows up during these missions
especially during the assault on the
archives as while we still have our
three-man group the others are still in
the level fighting other enemies if like
the full team was coming together to
solve Shepard's problem which makes the
idea of this being a loyalty Mission a
lot easier to understand once the Clone
and Brooks are defeated the party can
start the party in Anderson's apartment
is probably one of the greatest missions
in this Trilogy it's such a fun
experience and just like any normal
party you never want the fun to end
you're allowed to invite whoever you
want but most people will likely invite
everyone they can this makes the party
even better as you can go between groups
and see who people are up to grunt was
having fun denying people who were
trying to enter the party Kasumi was
snooping around Shepard's drawers zaeed
javik and Rex were all intoxicated and
trying to shoot a line of bottles grunt
got drunk and needed to sit under the
shower water most of the crew starts
dancing at one point Shepard does an
incredible job of saying dialogue I had
no intention of saying James wants to
see how biotics work by having Liara
pick him up Z tries to hit on Samara but
it's sadly not working and a dozen more
things I don't have time to bring up I
must have spent an hour here just
listening to the people and being in the
moment to win the festivities the crew
takes a photo together and it really
highlights how far everyone has come it
also really puts into perspective how
bad the Renegade playthrough is since
the party is a very different experience
as with most parties though just about
everyone is too drunk to leave so they
all sleep over and just like the morning
after the party everyone is either
extremely awake too hungover to
socialize or already left before
everyone gets up like I said earlier
even if you hate the plot about the
Clone trying to take Shepard's identity
I think toughing it through just to get
to the party is well worth the effort
once the guests have left though you can
also invite people over individually for
some personal hangout time as well as
going to the silver Sun strip just like
the Citadel and meeting with some of the
crew most of it is either just excuses
to connect with the crew again or just a
chance for the game to throw in some
more comedy but probably the most
important one though is the memorial for
Thane the crew will end up coming by
again and say a couple words and it
really showcases the love this group has
not just for Thane but for each other
they may tease and know the [ __ ] out of
each other sometimes but they all care
about one another cool yet also tells
Shepard that he plans to talk to the
salarian counselor with I hope that some
solarian scientists can make a
breakthrough on a cure for Capital
syndrome he also gives us some video
clips that they wanted to send to
Shepard but didn't manage to
Citadel though is a really sweet DLC and
easily the best one in the game it's got
some great comedy and just being able to
relax with a lot of the crew and talk
about our adventures is one of the
greatest moments I've had playing this
Trilogy it's a love letter to the series
and a love letter to the fans from
BioWare Thanking us for playing the
series that they created it's a great
DLC on its own but it's also a beautiful
way to send off the Mass Effect Trilogy
and that right there is the reason why I
wanted to cover this DLC last as it
would have been a great way to send off
the video but clearly I didn't do that
which is a real damn shame because it's
all downhill from here and it all starts
with Leviathan Leviathan on its own may
not seem like a bad DLC and in hindsight
it's really not but to understand the
DLC we must understand the ending so for
now I'll be talking about its story then
circling back to my thoughts on this
later once we do cover the ending but
basically Leviathan starts with us
talking with a Dr Bryson who works on
the Citadel he's the lead researcher on
a project that was focusing on finding
out more about the Leviathan of DS the
Leviathan of DS was a corpse found on a
batarian planet many assume it to be of
Reaper origin but more importantly this
thing seems to have died a long time ago
and it's possible this creature or
species that killed it still exists Dr
Bryson was tasked with finding this
being that killed the reaper he ends up
getting killed though and after some
investigative work we Define the
location of a research facility where a
doctor Garner Works who just happens to
know more about this mysterious creature
we don't find anything sadly but we do
notice that the creature is aware of us
chasing it it also indoctrinated the
workers here over 10 years ago in order
to keep itself hidden we learned that it
can indoctrinate and spy on the Galaxy
using these orbs which we have seen
already in Mass Effect 1 and 2. once it
influences destroy Droid though the
workers come back to reality and realize
it's been 10 Years Part of Me wishes
more was done with this though since 10
years is a lot of time for anyone yet
all we really see is the research was
freaking out of it despite the fact that
10 years can literally change a person's
body kind of reminds me when we talked
about Soma a couple months ago and even
referencing the events of Soma is a
pretty scary thing to think about once
this is over we go through lots of
talking and investigating which I
thought was pretty fun until we make it
to the location of the creature we then
lands on a base floating in the ocean
and take a deep sea diver down about
3000 meters until we reach the creature
literally called Leviathan see Leviathan
isn't a being but a race of beings you
might notice how similar they look when
sat next to a Reaper and this is
intentional long before the events of
the game about a few million years ago
the leviathans were the dominant species
of the Galaxy since they were so strong
they made the less powerful species pay
tribute to them in exchange for
protection over time though they
realized that each of these species were
wiped out by their own creation they
couldn't allow this to happen since if
the species are dead then the leviathans
don't gain any tributes from them after
some analysis they realize that each
species was killed by synthetic life as
these species evolved they needed more
attack to sustain their life which is
why they turned through synthetic
Creations but over time those Creations
killed them off in Mass Effect terms
think of the Geth taking over and
killing everyone in the Galaxy Tyrion
solarians humans all the races would be
dead with the exception of the Geth this
happened to every species that they
surveyed so they needed to find a way to
prevent this from happening the
leviathans then decided to create an AI
that'd be tasked with solving this exact
problem however the solution involved
betraying the leviathans it created a
race of beings built in their image that
was made to destroy any advanced
civilization that crossed its
metaphorical point of no return We of
course know them as the Reapers the
Reapers look like the leviathans because
they were made by Leviathan AI the AI
then killed the leviathans and made the
first Reaper using their Essence who we
know as Harbinger who we saw back in
Mass Effect 2. if you're wondering how
intelligent they must actually be if
they thought solving a conflict between
synthetic and organic life would meet
the assistance of a synthetic AI well
they actually mentioned that simply put
since the leviathans were so successful
in being the packs of the Galaxy they
thought everything was beneath them and
at the end I was just one of their tools
it makes sense even if it is still dumb
but their mistake is what started the
cycle however they don't see it as a
mistake the AI was built to preserve
life in the galaxy and it is doing just
that they just didn't think they'd be a
part of the harvesting process firstly
it's quite hilarious how the reaper on
ranox said their goals were
incomprehensible seems pretty coherent
to me but secondly I want to clarify
that advanced Life part in case some of
you are still confused we know thanks to
javik that the prothean saw all the
races of the world grow so if they
wanted to wipe out all life they should
have killed everyone but they only
destroyed the protheans way back in Mass
Effect 1 we talked about the Fermi
Paradox and the great filter if we bring
that image back again we can now say
that the step 10 is synthetic life
killing off organic life the reapers are
basically killing anyone who make it to
step 9 and are showing signs of
approaching step 10. it's not the best
example but it does explain whether
Reapers didn't kill Humanity when they
fought the protheans humanity at the
time wasn't powerful enough to master
space travel so they weren't even close
enough to developing AI powerful enough
to kill themselves that's why the
reapers are fighting us now since while
the Geth make a pretty good case for
synthetic killing organic life the
Reapers don't want to destroy the Galaxy
they want to save it their end goal is a
good one but how they go about achieving
it that being the Cycles is the problem
as organic beings with free will we
should decide on our own when we die but
the reapers are cutting that short which
is why we fight back we see it as
survival the Reapers just see it as part
of the cycle also you may be wondering
about the death since we did broker
peace between the Geth and the corians
ultimately disproving that synthetic
life will always kill organic life
and yeah that's one thing I'm
disappointed about Leviathan and the
ending don't acknowledge that we were
able to do this and seeing as we're
already talking about it I think it's
time we discussed the ending
Mass Effect 3's ending technically
starts at the Cerberus headquarters but
most of the complaints regarding its
endings start when we go back to Earth
Admiral Hackett tells us that once we
start the attack on Cerberus there's no
time to prepare so we must make sure we
have as many War assets as possible
because we're past the point of no
return honestly the Cerberus
headquarters is a decent Mission nothing
too exciting happens here besides this
killing Kai Lang which I'm all for and
the fact that we learned about Edie's
origin as a refresher the main reason
we're here is because Kai Lang stole the
prothean vi back on desio so we need to
get it back Shepard predicts that they
hit it in the most secure part of the
station which just happens to be the
elusive man's office we know this
because well the giant sun in the back
I'll be honest I always thought that was
fake but the Galaxy map proves that this
is real how have we not found him faster
that's like the biggest sun in the
Galaxy on the way to the core of the
station we can see that Cerberus took
the human Reaper from the last game and
has been experimenting on it regardless
of if you blew up the base or kept it
the human Reaper is still here so that's
another wasted Choice once you reach the
Via it tells us that the Catalyst the
thing we've been searching for all game
is actually the Citadel with The
Crucible and the Citadel combined the
explosion from the weapon will wipe out
the Reapers and win the war Shepard
decides that we need to go now but
that's not going to happen not only is
Kai Lang about to show up and stallless
but apparently the elusive man has
already made it to the Citadel and has
told the Reapers what our plans are
furthermore the Reapers have now moved
the Citadel to a reaper-controlled area
which just so happens to be right above
Earth once we take the vi and defeat Kai
Lang we then go to Earth and start our
assault Earth however is where the
problems start to trickle in at the time
of recording I had about 6 800 War
assets on a good playthrough and 2600 on
our bad playthrough it's not the ideal
setup as I could have gotten better
scores in each playthrough I think 7400
is the highest and somewhere around 1800
is the lowest but a 4 000 war asset
difference is still quite substantial
especially when you consider that one
almost fills the bar while the other
doesn't even reach the minimum
requirement the reason I bring this up
is because the war assets have been the
main mechanic of the game it's the thing
all the side quests and the main quests
have been built around and is the sole
reason a lot of our choices have been
very Sim simplistic so if it's the most
important then it should have a lot of
change sadly it doesn't
the first cutscene of the assault is
really well done Mass Effect has always
excelled when it comes to spectacle and
presentation and this is without a doubt
a great scene the only difference is
each playthrough has though is that
instead of this Reaper getting blown up
one of the aligned ships gets blown up
instead and the reaper is still alive it
is minor but it does show us that having
low War assets is going to get people
killed the other change that occurs is
the quarians and the Geth if one
survives and they report into Shepard
furthermore we can also see their fleets
in the background during the cutscene
and if one survives then a
representative will meet us at the
alliance base a bit later those
representatives are Tali or her and
admiron if she's dead or a Geth Prime
unit if the death were chosen it also
seems like the peace option defaults to
the quarian outcome meaning if the Geth
win then only the Geth show up if the
quarians win then only the corians show
up but if both broke her peace then it
just seems to be only the quarians for
some reason also random side note the
giant ship we see in the beginning is
not the destiny Ascension or at least
doesn't seem to be since I destroyed
that in the other playthrough and it
still appears after this Shepherd and
crew will then land again in the ground
assault most of it is fairly
straightforward and I did enjoy the war
torn cities of London even if they'd
become a bit samey after a while the
differences here are that if you didn't
do Cortez's side mission on the Citadel
then he'll die during the attack he'll
still get hit regardless but in our
Paragon playthrough he manages to pull
through furthermore if you have warrant
as a companion she'll appear as a
Banshee meaning the Reapers got to her
first this also means that we have now
officially killed every companion from
Mass Effect 2 as her and zaeed were the
only ones left and he died back on the
Citadel from here we get escorted to a
nearby Alliance base and then get the
chance to talk with some of our new crew
call our old crew and discuss the next
step with Anderson by now you may have
noticed that the gameplay has shown a
lot of alliance members and this is
probably my least favorite part about
the ending see Mass Effect 3 on launch
had a terrible ending it was probably at
the time the biggest gaming controversy
in a long time I haven't seen this much
hate towards something gaming related in
ages nowadays this is a monthly
occurrence since games are released have
finished and some devs over promise and
under deliver but back then this was
different Mass Effect 3's ending was
rushed to import poorly thought out
because of that one of the dlc's release
for the game was called Extended Cut
That solely focused on fixing the ending
now most of the problems with the ending
will happen in a couple minutes from now
but it is starting to show its layers
already the cutscenes we have seen are
the same thing in both playthroughs
furthermore there was no acknowledgment
of our choices each of the cutscenes in
this ending show tyrion's solarian
Krogan and asari these are the default
guaranteed races that join us no matter
what even if we sabotage the genophage
or a cure it the Krogan will always join
us so BioWare added them in the cutscene
but races like the Geth corians volis
Alcor and even the smaller groups like
arya's mercs X Cerberus employees the
rachni and all the others never appear
because it's not guaranteed that a
player will get them on their team
getting the guests to join means we have
to make sure they win the war or broker
piece but as our playthrough show they
can die thus they're not guaranteed to
show up in the ending so any race that
isn't the four I just mentioned will not
appear in this ending with the one
exception that we saw earlier which was
the quarian fleet reporting in that is
ludicrous I wasn't kidding earlier when
I said that we would never see the
rachni queen or her people again that
side mission is literally the last time
arachni appears in the trilogy because
the game never shows them in the final
battle despite the fact that we saved
the rachni queen twice and the fact that
she promised us she would attack the
Reapers when the time comes she is never
seen again like I said these numbers and
these pictures are all fake it's just
numbers on a screen it's not tangible it
makes you feel like there's a ton of
different species coming together and
contributing to the war but they're not
getting back to the more positive stuff
talking with the crew both old and new
is really nice it's really just about
saying goodbye just in case things go
wrong because we're about to make the
final push Jeff also talks about ending
his life once this is over because he'll
have served his purpose and brought
Victory to the protheans it's sad but
makes sense the protheans are all dead
with him and the Reapers being alive are
the only reason he's still alive and
kicking his whole purpose in this
cyclist to defeat the Reapers and if we
do that well his purpose has been
fulfilled besides that all the others
were really sweet and I like this a lot
as it's not only just an opportunity for
Shepard to say goodbye to the crew but
for for us to say goodbye as well just
like the Citadel DLC it also really set
in how badly the Renegade playthrough
has gone since I literally couldn't talk
to anyone on the comms Channel since all
the old crew was dead the only crew I
had alive at the time from all the games
was Liara James and Edie but don't get
too happy they're not safe just yet
according to Anderson the plan is to
make it to this device they called a
conduit not to be confused with the
conduit for a Mass Effect 1 however this
is similar just not the same device to
get to this device we need to defeat the
reaper that is defending it that
requires us to get past the No Man's
Land zone so the tanks can get within
range of the reaper this is basically a
very long and unsurprisingly very tough
fight despite that I really enjoyed the
action that came from not just this
Mission but the whole assault it really
felt like the final push now as we just
mentioned the game doesn't exactly help
sell that idea too well but when you're
on the front lines fighting you do feel
it a bit once the reaper is destroyed it
is now time to run to the beam Harbinger
has come by though to stop us so it's a
Sprint to the Finish Line it was kind of
like when the Allied Forces stormed the
beaches of Normandy back on D-Day that's
the vibe I was getting from this anyway
basically don't worry about the person
next to you or the thing in front of you
just keep running and don't look back
this is also one part that was changed
during the Extended Cut since in this
scene your companions are presumably
running with you but then all of a
sudden they show up at the end of the
game just fine despite the fact that
pretty much everyone including Shepard
gets blasted by Harbinger the Extended
Cut added an additional scene where
Shepard takes the crew to the Normandy
so they can leave and get medical
attention the running then resumes and
Harbinger blast Shepard knocking almost
all of his armor off your companions
though will only survive if your War a
set score is high enough if it isn't
Harbinger kills them so goodbye to Liara
and James while the Running part is cool
so much is wrong with this scene one why
doesn't Harbinger have any dialogue he
and Shepard easily have the biggest beef
in the galaxy and Harbinger says nothing
throughout this fight honestly had the
game not said that Harbinger was
defending the beam I would not have
known that was even him also why didn't
he shoot the Normandy it was stationary
for over a minute long even if people
were rushing to the beam I'm surprised
that Normandy wasn't the first priority
since he seems to shoot the magos first
as they're clearly faster also once he
he kills everyone he leaves not only is
the Beam still on but who's to say that
someone else doesn't come in and enter
the beam it doesn't even have to be
Shepherd it could literally be anybody
there there are still thousands of
soldiers still alive in this fight so if
the conduit is so important why isn't
there a Reaper here at all times
furthermore why not just shut it off
they're clearly powered somehow so I
would assume there's some kind of off
switch all they had to do was turn off
the beam and boom the Reapers win one
Shepherd enters the beam we learn that
this is a processing room the Reapers
were taking humans and throwing them
here to be used for processing but
what's going on with the citizens of the
Citadel people still live on that thing
and another got teleported to Earth or
dragged here both of which would likely
be a problem for its inhabitants also
did the Reapers harvest the people on
the Citadel or are they just chilling in
their Apartments after this though we
hear that Anderson has made it inside as
well but he got transported somewhere
else he also managed to make it to where
we're currently going faster than us
despite getting there later than us and
the only reason they did this was so
that the elusive man could hold Anderson
hostage it's also very obvious that this
room exists for just this interaction
because why would someone build a
central room that is connected to
various other rooms with the only thing
of importance being a control panel the
control panel seems to open up the arms
of the Citadel which is similar to the
council's room from Mass Effect 1 but we
were already there and this looks
nothing like it so what they move the
arm control panel to its own room as we
approach we see that the elusive man is
fully indoctrinated and somehow uses
biotics to force Shepherd to shoot
Anderson I'm not annoyed at the fact
that the elusive man has biotics
although it is a bit weird we learned
that now I'm more concerned about what
he just did with them biotics are a
weird topic of discussion in Mass Effect
because there's never been a clearly
defined line as to where they stop
biotics can move obstacles teleport
someone a great distance suspend them in
the air and even drain someone of their
life force the thing is though is that
this just seems too far-fetched for
biotics you could claim that it's
re-protect but that wouldn't make sense
either as it's only Tech Mass Effect 2
clearly defines the differences between
Tech and biotics Kasumi and Tali were
Tech experts so if you brought Samar to
the tech section of the suicide mission
she would die the Reapers gave Sarah an
upgrades but they were Tech upgrades not
biotics regardless the ability to
manipulate someone to pull a trigger on
a gun seems way too far-fetched in the
world of biotics and unless I'm mistaken
this is the only time someone with
biotics has done this you would think a
lot of people would try to use this
power but we never hear anything about
it until this exact moment similar to
sarin though we can talk down the ellusa
man and have him kill himself if not he
dies anyway we just shoot him instead
apparently his biotic mind control
ability was on cooldown or something
with the elusive man dead Shepard and
Anderson opened up the arms of the
Citadel and wait to die the two are
severely injured and are likely not
going to make it and honestly had the
game ended here I would have been fine
with that but there's still more to go
The Crucible won't fire so Shepard goes
back to the control panel as if hitting
it again would have worked collapses and
then gets taken up to the top of the
Citadel the thing controlling the lift
is the Catalyst the Catalyst was not the
Citadel it was an AI this is the AI that
the leviathans created to stop
synthetics from killing organic life as
such we already know its goals and its
intentions here's the issue without the
DLC this is the first time we're hearing
about the Catalyst and what it wants to
do it also never mentions the leviathans
at all during its dialogue so we're
unaware that this race of beings even
exists and the fact that it created the
Reapers from them the Catalyst also goes
on to say most of the stuff Leviathan
already said about synthetics always
killing Organics
which is infuriating because even though
we taught Edie how to be organic created
an organic and synthetic relationship
between her and Joker and stop the death
in the corns by brokering peace between
them we can never say this to the
catalyst this would immediately disprove
its entire argument yet we're not
allowed to say anything we just have to
accept that the AI is right I know that
in cases such as this you should
probably focus on the rule rather than
the exception but this exception is huge
not only is what we did the opposite of
what the Catalyst thought would happen
but our solution completely undermines
its whole argument so in this case the
exception should be considered but it
doesn't doing all this change is nothing
the extended card also changes a line
from the Catalyst as it brings up how it
knows about The Crucible yet it never
made any attempts to remove its data you
know the thing the Reapers do every
cycle well the extended card adds a line
that says that the Catalyst knew about
it but thought its data was gone this
line is a really good representation of
the whole ending because while the
Extended Cut does go to Great Lengths to
patch things up it's like putting a
Band-Aid over a bullet wound the only
way to make this ending better is to
completely overhaul the whole thing from
the start continuing the absurdity this
final three minutes also changes the
whole theme of the game without any
Rhyme or Reason Mass Effect 3 and
arguably the series has been about Unity
I mentioned in Mass Effect 1 how one of
the themes of this game is synthetic
versus organic life and that is still
true but is only part of the game AI is
something that is considered dangerous
which is why the council put in numerous
restrictions it's not the main theme but
it is one part of the game that does
connect to the game's main theme this
ending completely flips it on its head
and says that Mass Effect 3 and possibly
the trilogy has always been about
Organics vs synthetics this is so very
clearly not the case and all it takes is
one playthrough of the trilogy to
realize that all the races in this game
have broken fractured intense
relationships the turians and the
solarians Neutered the Krogan this
caused tension to occur between them the
asari are more focused on hiding State
secrets and preserving protein Tech than
getting into other races Wars Humanity
was shot at the first time they saw
alien life and some turians and humans
still haven't forgotten that war the
races of this world tolerated each other
not accepted each other it wasn't until
this world-ending threat came along that
the races of the Galaxy finally got
together and even then it took ages for
that to happen since Shepard had to do
most of the work on his own Mass Effect
3 is really where the races of the
Galaxy finally accepted at each other
and realize that there are more
important things at stake than Petty
rivalries and secrets once again that's
not to say Organics versus synthetics as
a theme didn't exist it most certainly
does but it was sort of a background
plot that fed into the history of some
of the races like with the quarians the
ending in the Leviathan DLC are the only
pieces of content that claim the
opposite which is why I have such an
issue with it Leviathan seems to be a
DLC that was retroactively added into
the game as a response to the criticism
surrounding the ending the only proof I
have though is a blog post from 2012
that states that the production on it
began after the release of the game the
only issue is that the Leviathan of DS
was something that was briefly mentioned
all the way back in Mass Effect 1. so it
is possible that the team had this idea
for a while that's what makes this so
hard to talk about because it could have
just been a DLC that had been planned
since the beginning but it just as
likely could have been a DLC that was
made in response to the ending and the
fact that Leviathan and the ending are
the only pieces of content to connect to
one another makes it seem like that's
the case a lot of these problems
regarding the central theme of the game
could also be attributed to what we
talked about in Mass Effect 2 regarding
the Dark Energy plot if you recall we
mentioned intoli's loyalty Mission how
haystrom's son was abnormal I said this
was supposed to be a tease of the events
to come regarding Dark Energy it seems
like the Reaper's main motivations for
killing life was to prevent dark energy
from being used because too much of it
would basically cause an explosion or
some kind of heat wave that would kill
off all life in the galaxy
this was going to be somewhat explored
until the main writer left the company
which is why we have the current plot
oh okay enough about the ending what
about the choices the Catalyst provides
Shepard with three choices one is
controlling the Reapers one is
destroying the Reapers and the other is
merging organic and synthetic data to
create a synthesis there is a fourth
option that was added in the Extended
Cut called refusal where Shepard just
gives up but I never found that ending
to be satisfying so I won't mention it
much as for the controlling part the
Catalyst says that the elusive man was
correct you can control the Reapers but
they already controlled him so he could
never be the one to control the Reapers
Shepard can however because he's not
indoctrinated in the destroy ending
Shepard blows up this tube which somehow
fires The Crucible killing all synthetic
life this also includes partially
synthetic beings which also mean
Shepherds and Cerberus rebuilt him
synthesis requires Shepard to merge his
body with The Crucible so that everyone
can have similar DNA and controlling
requires him to give up his physical
body to basically be an AI that controls
the Reapers so no matter what happens
Shepard is not making it out of here
alive that is unless you have 7 400 more
assets and thus a shortcut scene appears
after the destroy ending showing Shepard
taking a breath this to many is the
perfect and Canon ending of Mass Effect
3 specially given the recent trailers
about the new Mass Effect game
regardless what exactly happens when
these endings occur
I don't actually know the endings were
made to be vague BioWare wanted the
community to speculate and theorize as
to what the endings could mean but they
gave us so little information that it's
impossible to theorize the destroy
ending is probably the most coherent of
the bunch as synthetics dye and Organics
live simple synthesis is a bit better
because Edie says that peace was created
and that given enough time the Galaxy
may even transcend mortality itself the
control ending though is the one with
the most vague story because the
shepherd AI takes control of the Reapers
but we never hear what happens the only
thing that is shown is that the reapers
are being used to repair the mass relays
most of the dialogue is fluff such as
when he says with knowledge comes power
or how it'll be a guardian for the
people of the Galaxy all these endings
share a common theme and that's that
they're telling us what could happen and
not what did happen BioWare has shown
though that they can make proper endings
because every Dragon Age game has ending
slides that show the outcomes of your
choices now obviously BioWare has
multiple teams so it's quite possible
the Mass Effect team never interacted
with the Dragon Age one but still this
isn't a foreign concept because because
obsidian and Bethesda did it with
Fallout 3 in New Vegas Fallout New Vegas
has the much better end slide so I'll
just be using that as an example to
explain what I mean it's all right if
you've never played the game before but
basically you have to choose a faction
to side with at the end of the game
choosing a faction though changes the
game's setting if you chose the NCR you
discover that after some time all the
Mojave fell under their Banner but the
game doesn't just stop there because it
also tells you how the other places and
groups were affected by their rule such
as the fiends who end up fighting the
NCR and will win or lose depending on
whether or not a certain side quest was
done or the people of goodsprings the
first town you visit in the game they'll
be forced to leave town since the NCR
tax was too high for them to pay Fallout
New Vegas not only has endings that
change depending on the main faction but
also how those factions interact with
the lesser-known groups of the Mojave
furthermore all of what I said and more
is explained in the game itself fault
New Vegas tells you what happened and
then lets you come up with what could
happen in the future if we were to apply
new Vegas's endings to Mass Effect 3 we
could say that with the shepherd AI
fully under the control of the Reapers
the Galaxy was able to rebuild faster
than if they hadn't had them at their
disposal but maybe because we killed the
gathon ranok the AI could possibly make
things worse because it discovered that
synthetic life was wiped out for no
reason and thus becomes the new Catalyst
but if we only save the gath and killed
the corians maybe the same outcome
happens anyway but it's because it sees
synthetic life as Superior to Organics
the peace option would be the one choice
that stops the AI from becoming another
Catalyst now admittedly I just came up
with that on the spot and it's probably
not a great ending in hindsight but that
wasn't the point I want you to see
though what could have happened had Mass
Effect 3 did something like New Vegas it
would give us a chance to see the
immediate future as a result of our
actions and also see how small our
choices created the overall narrative
that makes up the epilogue of the
trilogy this would then lead to
community discussion as to what the
future could be would the AI attack the
Galaxy again using the Reapers or would
it go into hiding those are the what
could happen questions that come from
details we learned in the ending but as
it stands now none of that appears in
these endings that's why Mass Effect 3's
ending was originally so disappointing
and it's still disappointing now because
after three whole games and hundreds of
hours our choices come down to three
paths with vague explanations that's why
I created the Renegade playthrough
because I wanted to see how drastic
things were yet that didn't happen
either some of the end slides do show
some change like the chonka remaining a
Barren Wasteland because we didn't care
the genophage and the Earth being
completely scorched but that's probably
the biggest change the only reason I can
think of as to why this issue with the
playthroughs happened is because the
game is afraid to give out bad outcomes
even the refusal ending the ending where
we literally give up it still has a
substantial amount of optimism in it
since it shows liara's time capsule in a
base talking about their war with the
Reapers the other big disappointment was
the companions there are no slides that
talk about our companion's deaths it's
this black and white remember the Fallen
kind of thing and not Shepard had
absolutely blew it when raiding the
collector base and got everyone killed
in the process what an awful leader she
ended up being
the game would rather just omit them
from the ending entirely rather than
show the player the consequences of
their actions which is not only strange
because a lot of people died but it's
confusing because honestly none of this
is really a happy ending to use The
Crucible effectively we had to shoot the
pulse to all the mass relays which
completely destroyed them not only did
they not explode like the one in the
arrival DLC that killed 300 000
batarians but the game never brings up
how this could literally [ __ ] the
entire galaxy the mass relays are the
most important piece of technology in
the universe they're also the sole
reason the races of the galaxies made it
to where they are today it's also the
most used piece of technology and now
that's gone so no one can use faster
than light travel everyone is stuck on
their current planet or solar system
so just about everything in this ending
is a happy optimistic look towards the
future but the one part that is actually
terrifying to think about is never
mentioned and is just pushed to the side
why
it's also Canon that these blew up
because the most recent Mass Effect
trailer that came out a year ago still
shows them blown up to top it all off
and probably the funniest scene in the
entire ending the crew or lack thereof
come together to put Shepard on the
Memorial Wall I never talked about this
but the memorial wall has existed in the
Normandy for the whole game it's a
really subtle way to show how the war
has affected everyone around us Shepard
of course gets put on the wall because
he died but the wall is wrong the top
people on the wall are Caroline and
Charles but on the actual wall it's not
BioWare forgot to add the first five
people on the memorial wall so this
isn't even the correct number I think
the reason this exists is because in the
final mission Edie Liara James javik and
Cortez can die so they removed the first
few names to make room for the others
because in the Renegade playthrough
their names appear but still why did
they remove the other crew members names
plus that's also assuming they died in
the Paragon playthrough none of these
five did yet their names are still
removed furthermore the game has this
strange epilogue where someone called
Stargazer talks about the story of
Shepard basically the trilogy and its
choices are now a tale of Legend that's
been passed down to other people over
time we have no idea who these people
are or when this is so it's really just
weird and out of place and if I want to
be really nitpicky similar to Tally's
old masculus photo this is just a stock
photo of a picture called winter space
you can just Google it but I just
thought that both of these scenes were
really funny because of how unpolished a
lot of it is and that's ultimately what
happens when a game gets rushed things
are broken lazy and unsatisfying the
ending is literally the reason the
thumbnail says disappointing because
I've never seen a game do so well in its
opening moments only to Fumble at the
one yard line Mass Effect 3 is a solid
game and it has an impeccable story and
is a wonderful entry in the Mass Effect
Trilogy it has some great missions and
it really starts to feel like the game
is going to end on such a good note it's
just a shame that the ending failed
twice if there was a part that BioWare
shouldn't have failed at it was the
ending I would have given it a pass if
it was the opening moments or somewhere
in Act 2 but it's the ending that took
the brunt of the problems that's a major
issue not just because this is an ending
to a game but because it's an ending to
a Trilogy a three-game long journey that
took people hundreds of hours to
complete filled with Incredible moments
Incredible characters incredible choices
and so much more all for it to be
worthless by the end and that's
heartbreaking to have to go through I
wasted so much time playing this Trilogy
only to be given that ending and ending
and partially a game that made my
choices worthless by either completely
overriding them or making the difference
so small it's not even worth talking
about an ending that didn't even
consider my choices and just decided to
not show any of the Allies I had
acquired on the journey and an ending
that any person can get regardless of
the choices they made Mass Effect 3's
ending is bad thankfully it does not
sour the taste of the whole trilogy the
meeting with Sovereign the companions we
grew attached to the successes and
failures we had along the way all of it
was incredible it's still one of the
greatest games of all time but the
journey was much better than the
destination
but apparently our journey wasn't even
close to over Mass Effect 3 to many
myself included felt like the end but
BioWare wasn't willing to end the series
just yet Mass Effect 3 sales numbers
show that the IP was nowhere close to
death but how do you make an entry in a
series that so tight-knit well I have no
idea but apparently BioWare did
we'll talk about that another time
thank you all for watching today and I
hope you enjoyed as opposed to the last
video I promise you will not have to
wait two months for Andromeda as I'm
already working on it as we speak so it
should be out either by the end of the
year or as soon as 2023 begins only
reason I say that is because I
personally haven't played Andromeda so I
have no idea how long it'll take to beat
regardless thank you all for the support
on not just this series but all the
videos in the past few months I'm not
sure if this is going to be the last
video of the year but just in case it is
thank you all for an incredible year the
growth and the support has been insane
and I can't thank you well enough also
keep an eye on the community tab as I
may have a few things I want to announce
as always though like the video if you
enjoy and subscribe if you're new and
thank you to my returning viewers for
coming back to another video take care
everyone goodbye